[Zene]
a következő vendégem szakács pál istván
aki székelyudvarhely következő
polgármestere lesz és egyben a hbc-nek a
az igazgatója és a tedex udvarhelynek a
az egyik megálmodója és alapítója és
szervezője többek között arról fogok
vele beszélgetni hogy milyen volt a
választási kampányon részt venni hogyan
készült fel erre erről a hatalmas
győzelemről mi a véleménye hogyan áll a
következő négy évhez a következő
munkához hogyan fog megbirkózni ezzel a
jövendőbeli hatalmas csapattal ami 220
főből áll de kérdezni fogom a
magánéletéről is és a jövendőbeli
terveiről a fiatalságról úgyhogy
tartsatok velünk hát mindenképpen
köszönöm szépen hogy elfogadtad a
meghívásunkat én most arra számítok hogy
egy nagyon izgalmas másfél órás
beszélgetés lesz rengeteg kérdéssel
jöttem én is és
és pár hallgató is beküldött így előre
egy egy néhány k kérdést úgyhogy ezekből
fogok személgetni és nem próbálok meg
strukturált lenni tehát hogy ha ha kell
akkor elkalandozhatunk bármilyen irányba
az első kérdésem az hogy sikerült-e
kipihenni magad igen mindenek előtt én
is köszönöm a lehetőséget nagyon
őrvendek hogy itt lehetek én
hozzátartozik az igazsághoz hogy nagyon
nehezen szerettem meg ezt a podcast
formátumot de utána hogy egyre inkább
gyakorolja az ember egyre inkább belejön
és egyre inkább rájön arra hogy hogy az
izgalmas és igazán érdekes részek azok
valóban a beszélgetés egy bizonyos
pontján túl kezdődnek amikor az ember
vagy azért mert az is lehet hogy azért
mert kellően fáradt de kellően őszinte
lesz és akkor jön neki a igazán már egy
pár forgatáson túl vagyok hogy tényleg
úgy belefeledkezzünk egy idő után abba
hogy kamerák előtt vagyunk tehát most
még én így körbenézek így érzem hogy
kamerák vannak meg fények de 10 perc
után már ugye a flowban benne leszünk
remélhetőleg és akkor akkor tényleg egy
egy kal y én pedig ígérem hogy hogy
végig őszinte leszek én azért elég sokan
ismernek is a városban tehát
tudnak történeteket az életemből
végigkövették úgymond akár a szakmai
akár az emberi pályafutásomat úgyhogy
nincs is igazán értelme nagyon
kendőzötten beszélni bizonyos dolgokról
szóval arra készülök hogy ez egy jó
vagány beszélgetés lesz kipihenten
érkeztem nem ide hanem haza ezelőtt egy
héttel ugyanis hát a a választások után
elutaztam egy eg ilyen
20 napos hosszabb szabadságra egyrészt
szükségem is volt rá hát pályakezdő
politikusként nyilván ez a
kampányidőszak az ért eléggé leterhelt
megviselt nagyon élveztem egyébként a
ömét merthogy feszegettem a határaimat
minden téren akár a munkabíróképességben
is tehát hogy azért én a politikusokat a
gyakorlott politikusokat is azért úgy
ismertem meg hogy hetente egy fél órát
volt
közünk egymáshoz beszélgettünk
projektekről tervekről támogatásokat
kértem bizonyos ügyekhez és nem
gondoltam bele egyébként hogy ők
elképesztően sokat tudnak dolgozni tehát
nagyon sokat dolgoznak ezek az emberek
és mindig volt egy ilyen előítéletem
hogy hát azért politikusnak lenni
eléggé laza dolog lusta dolog hogyha úgy
úgy akar úgy alakítja a napirendjét
ahogy ő szeretné tulajdonképpen ez nem
feltétlenül van így én azt láttam
azokkal az emberekkel akik most egy
kicsit szorosabb lett a kapcsolatom hogy
hogy ők azért nagyon sokat tudnak
dolgozni nagyon keveset alszanak és és
mindamellett tényleg frissek tudnak
lenni a nap utolsó órájában is szóval
nekem viszont ez egy megterhő megterhelő
és fárasztó időszak volt ennek
megfelelően elutaztam olyan országokban
jártam a volt olyan része ahol
egyáltalán nem voltam és volt olyan
ahova azért rendszeresen visszatérek
mert mert nagyon tetszik nekem ázsiában
voltam
egyébként feltöltődtem kicsit úgy m tem
el hogy ez ez azért egy egy nagy
győzelem egy siker volt egy picit meg is
ijedtem a számoktól lehet hogy majd
erről
fogunk beszélni és és úgy jöttem haza
hogy hogy azért én már ezt nagyon várom
nagyon várom a következő négy évet igen
hát ez amúgy érdekes amit a
politikusokról mondtál ugyanez a
tapasztalatom van meg a a a
vállalkozókkal is hogy valahogy úgy
képzeltem el hogy a az ilyen nagyon
befolyásos vállalkozók ilyen
vezérigazgatók hasonlóan élik az
életüket hogy valahogy mint a monopol
játéknak ott a a a a a borítóján van az
a cilinderes pasas amelyik így a
bőrszivart így szívja valahogy így
képzeltem el a nagyon gazdag
vállalkozókat de pont az ellenkezőjét
vettem észre pont az ellenkezőjét azt
hogy
hogy nagyon nagy a munka munkabírásuk
nagyon szívélyesen fogadják a fiatal
ségeket lelkiismeretesek legtöbbször
hiperkompetensek és produktívak úgyhogy
ez a szterotíp kép amit te a politikusok
amúgy nekem is megv volt ez és talán van
is de de egyre inkább azon gondolkozok
hogy hogy ez ez ez csak így lehet ahogy
mondod hogy rengeteg munkája kell legyen
benne valakinek ahhoz hogy hogy meg
tudjon maradni a politikába
és ez egy ez egy érdekes közeg ami engem
is érdekel úy ezért is hívtalak meg hogy
egy kicsit beszélget k erről engem mint
új ilyen new entryt gyakorlatilag igen
ilyen területen mi milyen félelmeid
vannak milyen mire számítasz milyen
fogadtatásba reménykedsz ilyesmiket
fogok kérdezni de talán megis kérdezem
hogy milyen félelmeid vannak ezzel
kapcsolatban ezzel az új pozícióval
kapcsolatban hú nyilván rengeteg azért
mert hogy én egy ilyen beállítottságú
ember vagyok alapvetően hogy szeretek
előreaggódni dolgokon
és és és hát milyen félelmeim vannak
most be fogok kerülni egy teljesen új
közegbe mások a
játékszabályok van egy hát valamennyire
összeszokott valamennyire felépített
csapat ami több 100 főből áll tehát hogy
most nem egy négy-öt fős munkaközösséget
kell megreformálni vagy újragondolni hát
jelen pillanatban igaz ez egy relatív
kérdés mert hogy vannak szociális
munkások akiket egyébként szintén a a
vagy szociális beállítottságú emberek
akik gyermek nevelnek otthon ilyesmi
velük együtt több mint 350 de hát csak a
polgármesteri hivatalhoz tartozik több
mint 200 ember ember úgyhogy ez
szakmailag is emberileg is egy nagy
kihívás hát most gondolhatod de az
inkubátorháznál mi amilyen eredményeket
elértünk és ezek azért bizonyos
értelemben nem kis eredmények mert hogy
most már egy európai ökoszisztéma
megismert bennünket tudják hogy
udvarhelyen létezik egy vállalkozó
inkubátorház tudják hogy vannak izgalmas
érdekes rendezvényeink nagy bánatunkra
nem tudják azt hogy vannak olyan
startupok akik innen indulhatnának el
mertogy egész egyszerűen startupok
tekintetében nem versenyképes egyelőre
sem székelyföld sem székelyudvarhely
sajnos de ezt egy kis csapattal értük el
és akkor én most úgy közelítem meg ezt a
dolgot hogy 220 emberrel noha tudom hogy
sokkal földhöz ragadtabb problémákkal is
kell foglalkozzunk de hát egy világot
meg lehet váltani hogyha ez a 220 ember
jó egy irányba hajtja evezi a hajó
gyakorlatilag úgyhogy nagyok az
elvárásaim kicsit talán naivv is vagyok
ilyen szempontból
félek attól hogy azt amit hat emberrel
bizonyos esetekben meg tudtunk oldani és
akár
időlegesen áthágtunk egy-egy szabályt a
cél
érdekében itt most nem is attól félek
hogy nem fogom hanem hogy hogy nehogy ez
egy nagy hiba legyen vagy egy végzetes
hiba és itt most nem arra kell gondolni
adott esetben hogy bárkinek bármilyen
nemű anyagi haszna származzon egy-egy
döntésből hanem azért mert jó indulatból
nagyon sietünk és nagyon akarunk
megvalósítani valamit nehogy olyan
bürokratikus
akadályokat lépjünk át ami amivel majd
később büntethetőek adott esetben
zsarolhatóak bármi ilyesmik leszünk
szóval ettől félek ebbe bele kell
tanulni ez most elindul egy ilyen
tanulási folyamat felvettem felveszem a
kapcsolatokat környékbeli polgárn
mesterekkel meglátogatom őket megnézem
hogy milyen nekik egy-egy napjuk
megismerem az ő munkamódszereiket
megismerem azt hogy ők kiket tartanak a
legfontosabbnak az ők intézményeikben
ezek nagyvárosok polgármesterei de
kisvárosok polgármesterei is
mindenképpen olyan emberek akiknek van
már bizonyos tapasztalatok r tettek
valamit az asztalra és tanulni tudok
tőlük hát tanulni egyáltalán nem szégyen
én szeretek is tanulni és ez nem is egy
olyan műfaj ahol ahol nagyon nagyon
sokat szabadna kísérletezgetni
meggyőződésem mert át kell venni
máshonnan jól bevált formulákat és
azokat itt
életbe léptetni gyakor a gyakorlatba
ültetni
tulajdonképpen és ebben nagyon sok
támogató van már kérdezték
polgármesterek hogy meglátogatom-ee őket
igényelk-e ilyen jellegű mentoringot
tulajdonképpen és igen abszolút igénylek
és és nagyon szeretném a jó példákat
áthozni ide és nyilván úgy gyakorlatba
ültetni hogy az azért udvarhelyi legyen
tehát hogy mi udvarhelyi városakok ennek
a városnak van egy más szellemisége
azért más székelyföldi városokhoz képest
tehát hogy mi magunk is élvezni tudjuk
ezt de erről egy kicsit beszélniél hogy
mi az a más szellemiség mert én is érzem
de úgy szavakat nehezen kapok
rá én azt gondolom hogy talán a
legjobban ott tudjuk megfogni ezt az
egészet hogy udvarhely az a város ahol
mindig mindenből általában lesz második
harmadik vagy negyedik tehát hogy
szeretjük a sokszínűséget
[Zene]
jó és rossz értelemben is néha kellően
bizalmatlanok vagyunk
és ez néha jó egyébként hogy nem bízunk
meg
valakiben vagy valamilyen más
szervezetben néha ez azért káros tud
lenni de látni kell azt hogy például a a
politikai sokszínűség is
székelyudvarhelyről indult mint mint
nagyon sok minden más azért mert mert
itt én azt gondolom hogy talán valamivel
több tenni akaró ember van mint
székelyföld más városaiban és
és ezt pozitívumként sorolnám fel
negatívumként viszont azt hogy ők a
tenni akarást mindenképpen egy másik
szervezetben próbálják elképzelni nem
akarnak egy adott szervezetben akár
harcokat is felvállalni ahhoz hogy az ő
hangjuk egy kicsit erélyesebb és
hangosabb legyen hanem azt mondják hogy
akkor létrehoznak egy másik entitást és
otm próbálják a saját akaratukkat a
saját
ötleteiket végigvinni ez szerintem
mindenképpen egy udvarhelyi sajátosság
egy udvarheikum ha úgy tetszik ü ühüm
igen ezt ezt én is így érzem amúgy és
valahogy ezen gondolkoztam hy vajon
csikszeredához képest talán az egyik
nagy különbség hogy rengeteg
adminisztratív munka van csikzeredában
mint megyeközpont és itt pedig mivel
nincs ezért adminisztrációs munka úgy
értem itt ezért a vállalkozói réteg ki
kellett találja ön magát tehát újabb és
újabb vállalkozások tehát hogy most nem
tudom hogy van-e ilyen statisztika a
fejedben azzal kapcsolatban hogy
egységnyi tehát egy lakosra eső hány
vállalkozás van itt udvarhelyen és
csíszeredában de gyanítom hogy jobban
áll udvarhely egy lakosra eső
vállalkozások számában mint mint
csikszerel érdekes mert ez nem tehát
hogy pont ezen a
statisztikai adaton meglepődnénk mert
nem feltétlenül állunk jobban
udvarhelyszék vagy csíkszéket
összehasonlítva az egy váll egy főre
jutó vállalkozá t illetően ezt most még
megnézem gerécinak illetve a regának is
vannak erről pontos felmérései de én úgy
emlékszem hogy pont ezen a téren nem
számottevő a különbség talán valamivel
jobban állunk hát amivel számottemű az a
vagy amivel ami egyértelműen
megfogalmazható az az hogy a a gdp-nek a
hány szárzalékát adja székelyudvarhely
vagy udvarhelyszék és ott kimagaslunk és
nem csak csíkszeredához viszonyítva
hanem
sepsizentgyörgyhöz
kézdásárhelyhez most nyilván vásárhelyen
nem tudjuk hasonlítani magunkat egyrészt
mert ott van egy egy-két óriás vállalat
most gondolok itt a gázvállalatra is de
másképp azt is látjuk hogy vagy másrészt
azt is látjuk hogy ott pont az autópálya
közelsége miatt a különféle
infrastrukturális
fejlesztések miatt ott azért most nagyon
sok nagy vállalkozás bement és ott
teljesen átalakul ez a ez a gazdasági
része is maros megyének vagy éppen
vásárhelynek és vonzásk körzetének
igen rengeteg kérdésem lenne amúgy ezzel
a jövőbeli
polgármesteri pozícióddal kapcsolatban
de úgy érzem hogy nem faér hogy
elmenjünk amellett a temérdek dolok
mellett amit eddig is letettél az
asztalra és csináltál nem tudom hogy
hányan tudják a hallgatók közül hogy te
vagy a szervezője a kitalálója az egyik
szervezője a tedexnek és a a szeretném
hogy egy kicsit beszélj erről hogy ez
miért indult
el hogyan jött az ötlet és mi a
jelentősége ennek és a környéken még
hány hasonló tedex van igen hát hogyha a
kitalálója nem is hát ezt azért
páfikinga kezdeményezte ő ő nagyon jó
barátságban volt az akkori
marosvásárhelyi a tedex
marosvásárhelynek a a főszervezőjével
kurátorával és ő kezdeményezte azt hogy
akkor próbáljuk meg a tedexet áthozni
székelyudvarhelyre is és egyből megértő
fülekre talált holott egyébként bennem a
akkor nem volt meg ez a ted szellemiség
az az igazság nem néztem nagyon sok ted
videót egy párat azért igen és nem
értettem hogy mit jelent ez és így így
közben szerettem meg ezt az egészet és
és elsősorban a közösségnek hála tehát
hogy ott 3-400 olyan értékes ember volt
zömmel azért udvarhely székiek székely
udvarhelyiek hogy azt mondtam hogy hogy
én én nagyon jól éreztem magam minden
egyes tedex udvarhelyen és legt többször
nem csak az előadások nyilván azoknak is
megvan a maga értéke hanem az a közösség
amiben lenni tudtam tehát hogy tényleg
úgy gondolom hogy egy napra sikerült egy
olyan közösséget megmozgatnunk aki amely
nagyon értékes egy olyan eseménybe ami
azért rengeteg networkinget tartalmaz és
nagyon vagány ötrletek jöttek létre és
annak hogy most van székelyudvarhelyen
agy tedex udvarhely nagyon sok más
mindennek volt az elindítója vagy a
mozgatórugó ja hogy hogy ott tudtak
találkozni ezek az értékes emberek a ted
abban különbözik minden más
konferenciáktól hogy egy gondolatot egy
megtapasztalt gondolatot kell átadni és
abból tudnak tanulni tulajdonképpen a
résztvevők azok a résztvevők is akik
jelen tudnak lenni a teremben és hát
minden tedex videó a később felkerül a
tet hivatalos honlapjára a youtube
csatornájára úgyhogy senki nem marad le
róla ezek ingyenesen visszanézhetőek é
és és udvarhelyen nagyon bevált ez a
műfaj egy kicsit udvarhelyesítettük is
én azt gondolom hogy igényessé tettük és
nem akarok megbántani más tedex
szervezőket ezért volt szerencsém
eljutni majdnem minden környező város
tehát erdély összes tedexére én azt
gondolom hogy a miénk egy kimagasló
színvonalú networking tekintetében is és
évről évre próbálunk
javulni speakerek előadók szempont ából
is mindig vannak hullámvölgyek ez egy
nagyon nehéz dolog a az előadók
kiválasztása főleg azért mert ezt azért
nagyon erősen szabályozza a tet hogy
senkinek nem fizethetünk az előadásért
ezt nagyon kevesen tudják tehát amikor
ide eljönnek a legnagyobb nevek
magyarországról romániából ők ők soha
nem kapnak fellépti díjat vagy gázsit
igyekszünk a tenyerünkön holdazni
megmutatni székelyudvarhely
udvarhelyszék szépségeit nagyon jó
ételben italb ban ellátásban részesülnek
de egyébként gázsit nem kapnak és és és
még más ilyen hasonló szigorú
szabályzatok vannak hogy noha gázsit nem
kapnak de például az előadás teljes
anyagát előre hány héttel kell el
elküldjék scriptet kérünk szeretjük
hogyha elpróbálják előre ezt az előadást
még így is szokott beesni egy-két nem
odaillő vagy egy-két nem feltétlenül
színvonalas előadás de de hát ez ez ez
elnézhető én azt gondolom nagyon büszke
vagyok arra hogy egy ilyen városban
100%-osan online jegyeladással 10-15
perc alatt tudunk eladni 4500 jegyet ez
ez szerintem egy nagyon szép eredmény
nagyon büszke vagyok arra hogy olyan
licencünk van ami feljogosít arra hogy
akár 1500 főt is befogadjunk és ez már
ad is egy újabb kihívást hogy legyen
egyszer székelyudvarhelynek egy olyan
konferenciaközpontja ahova be tudunk
fogadni egy 1000 főnyi
közönség is és akkor hozzunk ide
országos vagy akár nemzetközi
konferenciákat is ez egy olyan piac
amire még senki nem harapott rá a
környezetünkben nincsenek ilyen nagy
termek színvonalasak és mi azért elég
sok mindenben így jeleskedünk tehát hogy
szálláshelyeink száma az nem rossz
székelyföldi városokhoz képest
kiemelkedően jó én azt gondolom ezek
színvonalasak is de vannak olyanok is
amik amik minden pénztá tehát
pénztálcabarátabbak is vannak nem csak
wellness hotelek itt a környéken és hát
ezt tudni kell a konferencia turistákról
hogy ők jó turisták ők érdeklődőek
hiszen azért jönnek el egy szakmai
rendezvényre is fejlődni akarnak nem
ülnek egész nap a szállodában tehát meg
akarják ismerni a környéket ahol jelen
vannak szóval szóval mindenki nyer nyer
a sarki közértes nyer a a vendéglátós
nyilván nyer a a hotel maga ahol
megszállnak ezek a turisták és és hogyha
egy jó képet tudunk bemutatni a városról
akkor a napvégén a legnagyobb nyertese a
székely hiszen ezek az emberek elmennek
és jó hírünket viszik majd és akkor
valószínű el fognak jönni még ismerősök
barátok hogy megismerjék ezt a ezt a
közösséget tehát van egy ilyen
hozzáadott értéke is ennek a ennek a
konferencia turizmusnak és igen elmentem
az egyesült államokban atlantában ott
volt egy ilyen ted wiman nevezetű
rendezvény és ott kellett megszerezni a
licenct volt egy pár napos műhelytábor
és ott tudtuk megszerezni ezt a licenct
aminek köszönhetően hát az országban
nagy nagyon kevés ilyen tedex rendezvény
van hogy hogy törvényesen tud beengedni
több mint 100 résztvevőt mi már azért
igen
hát ez tényleg elképesztő én már
többször részt vettem rajta és nagyon
élveztem és mint jövendőbeli
polgármester azt hiszem hogy akkor ez is
a hatalmatban vagy a a a kompetencia
körödben lesz hogy egy ilyen
eseményközponton elkezdjünk
gondolkozni izgatottan várom
kicsit még mesélj a hbc-ről hogy mi is a
hbc meg mi a mi a jelentősége ennek a
hány évet hány évet is vezetted a hbc-t
hát 2017-ben első intézmény vezetője
voltam egy egy vadonatú intézménynek
úgyhogy ez egy nagy áldás azért
mert nem volt előítélet voltak elvárások
egy alapvetően
túlméretezett inkubátorházról beszélünk
egy ilyen kis közösségben azért nem
nagyon jellemző hogy egy 48 iroda
helyiséges
inkubátorházat három emelettel
felhúzzanak és azt mondják hogy ezt
akkor élettel kell megtölteni úgyhogy
ott is kellő aggódással és félelemmel
vágtunk neki a
munkának tényleg nagyon szerencsés
vagyok mert egy nagyon jó csapat jött
össze és meggyőződésem hogy ez is volt a
kulcs a sikerhez hogy minden téren olyan
kollégám volt aki szakmailag felkészült
volt és legyen az kommunikáció legyen az
közbeszerzés legyen az jogi tanácsadás
legyen az különféle projekt menedzsment
kérdés a legjobb kgákkal tudtam együtt
dolgozni
és és igazából ez az intézmény olyan
lett mint amilyen mi vagyunk nagyon sok
helyen nagyon sok szervezetnél azt
látjuk hogy és legyen ez a sarki abc
legyen ez egy kórház deá tényleg a
legnagyobb szervezetekig is hogy
bizonyos idő után az épületnek vagy az
intézménynek vagy a szervezetnek a képe
az a vezető képéhez képével am azonosul
és és nálunk tényleg azt gondolom hogy
az inkubátorház olyan lett mint amilyen
mi a menedzsment csapat vagyunk
szakmailag rendben van de azért kellően
laza mindenféleképpen mindenkivel szóba
állunk egy biznis környezetet
alakítottunk ki és ezt nagyon fontosnak
találtam tehát mi közintézmény
ként szereplünk és ennek
megfelelően az első években főleg a
bevételünk ilyen
70-80%-át azt önkormányzatok adták
megyei tanács városi önkormányzat és
oroszhegyközség önkormányzata ezt mára
sikerült
rornázni 30%-ra és 70%-át mi magunk
teremtjük elő a elő az összegnek amiből
gazdálkodni tudunk és ráadásul ez az
összeg folyamatosan nőtt még az első
évben volt egy ilyen 600000 lees
költségvetésünk most már kettő k éés fél
millió lees az összbüzséje a a hbc-nek
és és igaz mint közintézmény nagyon
sokat kellett az első években azért
harcolni hogy hogy ez más legyen mint a
többi és igaza volt annak a hölgynek is
aki a megyei tanácsnál jelezte hogy jó
jó de sajnos olyan iskolák vannak főleg
vidéken ahol nincsen
nincsen wcpír és akkor mi szoktuk kérni
azt hogy hát nálunk legyenek ilyen
kéztörlők vagy legyen és akkor el
kellett mondjuk nekik hogy jó de ez egy
biznisz közegi de más emberek jönnek
mást szeretnének itt konkrét üzleti
kapcsolatok valósulnak meg a napvégén
ami gdp-t termel a városnak a megyének
az országnak adott esetben tehát hogy
itt itt meg kell legyen ez a része is a
dolgoknak rengeteg értékes embert
ismertünk meg
előadókat nagyon sokkal barátság is
alakult ki tehát láthatjuk azt hogy
visszatérő vendégeink vannak például egy
geszti péter
ő most már harmadszor volt talán nálunk
de tényleg azt gondolom hogy nagyon
értékes szakmailag mindenképpen a
krémjét tudtuk elhívni bizonyos
kérdésekben a vagy bizonyos olyan
kérdések igen bizonyos témakörökben
köszönöm
és amit még mindenképpen
a pro ként jegyeznék meg az az hogy nem
féltünk meghívni olyan embereket sem
akiket az aktuális
vezetés vagy az aktuális
közhangulat nem nagyon kedvel tehát mi
azt mondtuk hogy amikor pénzügyi
kérdésekről van szó nem szégyen elhívni
a magyar nemzeti bank vagy a magyar
pénzügyminisztert aki régebb volt x évig
azért mert most egy másik politikai
oldalon áll vagy egyáltalán néha
politizál nem politikusként hívtuk meg
és ezt megmertük tenni és nagyon sok
ilyen ember volt és én azt gondolom hogy
nagyon fontos a vállalkozókkal őszintén
mindenkivel nagyon fontos őszintén
beszélni tehát amikor majd rátérünk arra
hogy hogy mi lesz az egyik legnagyobb
változás az az hogy nagyon sokat fogunk
az emberekkel beszélni a városlakókkal
és ezt nagyon őszintén tesszük meg de a
vállalkozókkal is tehát amikor van egy
olyan gazdasági környezet egy olyan
változás ami részben politikai is és ami
nagyon érzékenyen érinti a vállalkozókat
hát most gondoljuk el hogy a kkv-k akik
akik 90%-át teszik ki a vállalkozásoknak
szembesülnek egy pandémiával
szembesülnek egy egy
emelkedéssel az energiapiacnál
szembesülnek
munkaerőprémákkal akkor nem foghatunk
mindent rá külső tényezőkre tehát fontos
lássák azt és ezt megfelelő szakértők
tudják elmondani hogy mi minek a
következménye és hol lehetett előre
látni azt hogy itt most be fog
következni egy hát ha reesszió nem is de
egy hatalmas lassulás gazdasági téren
hol kihibázott azért hogy ez
megtörténjen tehát főleg a vállalkozók
azok hiteles emberektől kell hiteles
képet kapjanak és az előrejelzések a
prognózisok is hitelesek kell legyenek
hogy tudjanak számolni mert hogy a
politikus néha hajlamos
nem megalapozottan pozitívan
előretekinteni a jövőbe és és fontos
látni azt a vállalkozóknak a reális
oldalt is és mi mindig igyekeztünk azt
megmutatni
igen ez a az egyik eseményeteken
értettem meg mélyebben a bölcsességét
annak hogy mennyire fontos tényleg a
közösség és mennyire fontos az hogy
házigazda legyen valaki tehát van egy
van egy bölcsessége annak hogyha
házigazdák vagyunk mert
előtte vállalkozóként főleg az első pár
évemet az jellemezte hogy minden időmet
igyekeztem abba fektetni hogy produktív
legyen tehát konferenciákra nem nagyon
jártam mert nekem veszteség időveszteség
volt egy napot kettőt rászánni valami
még időt pénzt még még talán el el is
utazzak otthonról a családom mül tehát
hogy nagyon nagyon-nagyon
igyekeztem mindent optimálisan
kihasználni az életemben és nem nagyon
értettem őszintén szóval hogy miért
szerveznek ennyi konferenciát sok helyen
miért miért ennyire népszerű a
konferencia miért jó egy konferencia és
miért jó a közösség emlékszem hogy most
így a a a vckker tulajdonosával árpáddal
amikor leültünk beszélgetni nekem nagyon
jól esett hogy azok a bölcsességek
amiket én megértettem neki teljesen
természetes volt tehát értette a
közösségnek a bölcsességét hogy miért
fontos közösséget építeni és az egyik
eseményen két éve talán egy karácsonyi
alkalom az it claster szervezte ültem és
gondolkoztam hogy ez a sok ember nem
találkozott volna most itt e ezek a
spontán beszélgetések a kávészünetekbe
annyira értékesek hogy talán nem talán
még értékesebbek is maguk min mint maguk
az előadások és az hogy találkozunk
egymással
ez ez főleg a a a covid után egy egy
luxus rá kellett jöjjünk a covid alatt
hogy hogy hogy a hogy az a belső
érzetünk hogy bármikor tudunk találkozni
hogy összefutunk az utcán majd leülünk
egyet kávézni ez egy ilyen tévképzet
mert mert nem ülünk le mert nem kapunk
rá időt mert folyamatosan sietünk és az
hogy találkozhassunk egy konferencia az
egy ez egy mesterséges megállás ilyenkor
kiszállsz a a hétköznapi rutinból és
mégis egy szakmai környezetben de egy
pihentető ünnepi környezetben ahol bőség
van ahol megihhatsz megehetsz valami
finomat ezért fontos hogy tényleg
bőségmentalitásban gondolkozzunk és ez
abszolút átjött a hbc-nek az az
eseményein amin amiket szerveztetek és
ezen az eseményen hasított belém az hogy
mennyi hozzáadott értéke van azért nem
éreztem addig mert nem egyértelmű a
hozzáadott nem mérhető a hozzáadott
értéke de attól hogy nem mérhető nem azt
jelenti hogy nincs és nekem
nagyon-nagyon szimpatikus volt amikor
azon részt vettem és utána
elgondolkoztam hogy én ebben részt
akarok venni segíteni akarom még akkor
is hogyha ha eddig nem vettem részt de
valamilyen formában mindenképpen
segíteni akarom majd az it clasternek a
tevékenységét úgyhogy é és abszolút
érzem tudom hogy te tudod ezt tehát hogy
látszik hogy áthatja a hbc-nek a
szellemiségét meg a tedex is emiatt jött
létre tehát gyakorlatilag az egy
intellektuális ünnep a tedex amikor a
város azon része amelyik részt szeretne
venni ebbe az intellektuális ünnepbe
eljön beszélgetnek jól érzik magukat
megisznak egy koktélt résztvesznek egy
koncerten meghallgatnak pár nagyon jó
előadást és az hogy becsúszik pár
közepes min őségű vagy gyenge előadás ez
igazából mindeg hát ilyen az élet minden
területén persze és pont teljesen
egyetértek azzal hogy talán a
legértékesebb időszakok azok az
ebédszünetekben a kávészünetekben az
ilyen networking partykban vannak amik
amik zárnak egy ilyen eseményt és a
kollégáknak is azt mondtam hogy nyilván
mi vállalkozókkal foglalkozunk ennek
megfelelően mindennek ára van tehát
nincsenek ingyenes eseményeink ára van
egy biznis reggelinek ára van egy
egésznapos konferenciának és ára van van
egy tedexnek is és nem azért van ára
mert mi ebből nyernénk nem de egyrészt
nagyon fontosnak látom azt hogy mi
hozzuk ki nullszaldóba az ilyen
eseményeket senkit ne etessünk itassunk
ingyen ez egy alapszabály nálunk és és
másrészt én azt mondtam az embereknek
hogy nem az ár adja az értéket tehát nem
attól értékes az eseményünk hogy el
tudunk adni nagyon hamar 7080 vagy akár
500 jegyet hogyha egy tedről beszélünk
hanem az hogy értékes tenni akaró vezető
beállítottságú emberek az idejüket
rááldozzák és azt az idejüket ami a
legértékesebb tehát most gondoljunk el
egy biznis reggelire ami amúgy is
egyáltalán nem volt a városban tehát ezt
a műfajt mi hoztuk ide be kimondottan
egy nagyvárosi luxus volt annó én
kolozsváron részt vehettem egyszer mint
előadó pont a törzsdéről beszéltünk egy
biznis reggelin és nekem nagyon
megtetszett és a reggel az a
legértékesebb időszak egy vezető számára
akkor a legfrissebb akkor vannak a
legfontosabb gondolatai akkor tudja ezt
a leginkább átadni a kollégáknak nem
véletlen hogy azért a legtöbb meeting a
legtöbb ilyen csapatbeszélgetés az a
délelőtti órákban szokott megvalósulni
mert akkor a legfogékonyabb a munkatárs
is átvenni az információt és a vezető is
akkor tudja a leg a legjobban átadni és
ezt a napszakot áldozzák fel azért azért
tényleg eredményes jó vezetők vál ók
arra hogy eljöjjenek és egy órát
másfelet reggelivel együtt nálunk
töltsenek és ez adja meg az értéket
abszolút és ez a kollektív
áldozatvállalás tehát amit most mondtál
hogy ez a legértékesebb rész ez a
kollektív áldozatvállalás összeköt amúgy
mindig mindig az áldozatvállalás köt
össze tehát hogy egy családon belül is a
az ha ha mindenki áldozatot vállal a
családban azért az a család egyben
maradjon az apa is és az anya is és és a
a gyerekek is akkor ez ez egy emlékként
összeforr és egy identitást ad ez a
kollektív áldozatvállalás most már
rendesen kiérzem a tedexnek azt a a
hangulatát amikor amikor találkozunk az
egy áldozat mert az időnkből áldozunk a
pénzünket áldozzuk rá a figyelmünket
áldozzuk rá de mivel a vasárnapot
áldozzuk rá és és azáltal hogy mindenki
ugyanezt teszi azáltal úgy érezzük hogy
ez egy ez ez ez összeköt minket úgyhogy
úgyhogy én nagyon örvendek neki hogy
hogy
ilyen alapgondolatokkal indulsz neki a
polgármesterségednek és kicsit most
akkor rátérnék erre a témára is mert
roppantul érdekel ez a fajta potenciál
amit most a kezedbe kapsz de a
potenciállal együtt jön a felelősség is
és tudom hogy hogy a felelősség terhe az
az azt érzed tehát erről akarok egy
kicsit beszélgetni de onnan kezdeném
hogy amikor spontánul leültünk
beszélgetni itt a médiaműhelynek a a
másik
termébe akkor az egyik
gondolatom az volt úgymond tanácsom
neked hogy ha nincs benned egy perszselő
igen akkor mondj nemet erre a felkérésre
hogy te legyél a polgármester jelölt én
mindenképpen az az az igazság hogy
bevallom hogy az egóat nekem is
csiklandozta hogy vajon milyen lenne
hogyha én indulnék el mint polgármester
de rájöttem nagyon hamar hogy ez ezt én
nem tudnám csinálni és a jelenlegi
élethelyzetemben én erre nem lennék
alkalmas a gyermekeimet nem szeretném
kitenni ennek a a a médiatűznek hogy
hogy mindenki rólam beszéljen és lehet
hogy ez fog majd rád várni hogy négy
éven keresztül exponenciálisan a
figyelem középpontjába fogsz kerülni és
nem csak pozitív hanem akár negatív
kontextusban is
nem tudom hogy van-e olyan politikus
amelyik amúgy csak pozitív kontextusba
kerül a médiába
be akkor láttam hogy nagyon gondolkozol
ezeken ezen a kérdésen hogy vállald- el
nem nem láttam egy erős igent utána ped
pedig mégis elindultál úgyhogy arra
gondoltam hogy hogy valami meggyőzhetett
és azt is tudom hogy sokan féltettek is
téged hogy hogy mi fog történni most
hogy hogy hogy ezen az úton elindulsz a
testvéred is írt egy nagyon megható
levelet tudom hogy édesanyád is óvott
ettől a
pozíciótól akkor az első kérdésem az
hogy miért mondtál igen mi változott meg
ak ahhoz képest amikor két hónappal
ezelőtt nem bocsánat ez már három
hónapja volt legalább három hónappal
ezelőtt amikor leültünk beszélgetni mi
az amiért mégis igen mondt
nyilván amikor és én egy reál
beállítottságú ember
vagyok amikor összeírtam a pro és kontra
érveket mert hát összeírtam mert hát
reál beállítottságú ember vagyok akkor
akkor nem győzedelmeskedett egyébként a
pro ühüm és gondom pontokat adtál igen
igen igen pontosan pontoztam ezt az
egészet minden szempontból megnéztem
most nézd egy olyan helyről jövök az
inkubátorházból ahol egy nagyon magagány
csapat van egy egy élmény velük dolgozni
nagyon vagány a közeg ott van a város
végén tehát nem is az van hogy betéved
valaki akinek egyébként nincsen ott
keresnivalója mert célirányosan jönnek
és jönnek tehát nem is az van hogy egy
üres épületben vagyunk nagyon izgalmas
és nagyon vagány embereket ismertem meg
nagyon jó a fizetés azért mert nagyon jó
európai uniós pályázatokat hozunk be
tehát van egy alapfizetés és ezt mindig
meg tudjuk fejelni egy vagy két eus
pályázattal per fő tehát anyagilag sem
éri meg ez a váltás beállítottságú
embernél az azért szintén egy szempont
tud lenni és végül érdekes talán
életemben először győzedelmeskedtek a az
emocionális szempontok ha így lehet
fogalmazni a tenni akarás a dü a
lelkesedés az hogy valamivel többet ak
akok és valamivel én azt gondolom hogy
többre érdemes ez a város is üüm hogy
bennünk azért több van tehát nagy a
potenciál és ezt nem tudtuk az elmúlt
évtizedekben kiaknázni
ki
kihúzni a a városból hogy dühös vagyok
hogy bizonyos helyzetek így alakultak
ahogy hogy nagyon sok minden nem
székelyudvarhelyre érkezett aminek itt
lett volna a helye hanem átengedtük más
városok nak engem én tényleg úgy állok
hozzá hát a versenyszférából érkezem
bizonyos szempontból bármennyire furán
is hangzik
közintézményvezetőként hogy itt egy
versenyhelyzet van városok között is és
mi
ebben ezt nem fogtuk fel tehát hogy mi
nem versenyeztünk soha senkivel
elvoltunk a magunk nyugalmával hogy van
itt a város hogy van itt ez a magyar
közösség hogy ez itt marad és ez már nem
annyira egyértelmű merthogy megváltoztak
az emberek is és a lelkesedés tehát hogy
én én tényleg lelkes vagyok ezért a
munkáért és
és azt merem gondolni mert hogy rengeteg
emberrel beszélgettem hogy talán tudom
hogy mit kell mit kellene min kellene
javítani ahhoz hogy jobb legyen élni
székelyudvarhelyen és és hát említetted
hogy igen a politikusoknak kimondottan
negatív szokott lenni a sajtójuk már már
az fura hogyha valakinek
pozitív sajtója van és akkor szoktunk
ilyen képzeteket tenni hozzá hogy hát
biztos akkor ez a médium vagy ez a
médiatermék ennek vagy annak a
tulajdonában van ezért írnak szépeket
róla vagy ezért nem bántják igen nyilván
ezzel is tisztában vagyok ráadásul ez
egy nagyon igazságtalan műfaj ezt meg is
tapasztaltam a a választási kampányban
ahol gyakorlatilag volt
egy média termék amelyik gyakorlatilag
hadjáratot indított ellenem ellenünk és
és nem volt amitre áljunk rá meg meg nem
is tudtam még akkor hogy egyáltalán erre
kell reagálni nem kell reagálni egy
ellenszer van egyébként erre k ez amúgy
melyik mégia volt még nem nem figyel nem
akarok most ebbe kimondottan belemenni
lejárt
[Zene]
egy ellenszere van egy ezeknek a
dolgoknak egyébként nagyon sokat kell az
emberek között lenni üüm és hogyha te
sokat vagy az emberek között és és
megpróbálnak olyan színbe beállítani
amilyen nem te vagy akkor főleg egy
kisvárosban azért ez egy kisváros és nem
hülyék az emberek tehát hogy az emberek
értelmesek és ezt megmutatják
választásról választásra ha úgy tetszik
tehát ők látják hogy mi zajlik a
közösségben látják azt hogy valami jó
irányba megy vagy nem és és nagyon éles
ellenpéldákat tudunk bemutatni tényleg
számok alapján hogy a közösség dönt és
hogyha engem meg próbálnak valaminek
beállítani ami nem vagyok akkor kellően
értelmes és kellően karakán ez a
közösség azt mondani hogy nem ő nem
ilyen tehát hogy ezt valaki megírta
úgyhogy én ezt látom egyébként a a
sikerkulcsának hogyha úgy tetszik a
városháza szempontjából is hogy ne
szakadjunk el az emberektől folyamatosan
menjünk konzultáljunk ne négy évente
jelenjünk meg ne négy évente döbbenjünk
arra rá hogy ugyanaz a kátyú egyáltalán
nem tömődött be ne négy évente mondják
azt a városakok mert elmondják nem
félnek ők hogy hát de polgármester úr ön
négy éve volt itt utoljára akkor is
meglepődött hogy itt van egy nagy kátyú
és most is jön és meglepődik és ezek az
emberek elmondják és azért mondják el
mert kisközösség és ismernek és tudják
hogy velem bármikor találkoz őszinték
őszinték az emberek
úgyhogy igen tehát hogy talán életemben
először az emocionális
részem dominálta a a reális részt ha úgy
tetszik vagy a reál beállítottságú
énemet én is meglepődtem tehát hogyha
most összefoglalom azt amit mondtál volt
benned egy dü egy elégedetlenség de ez
én íy pozitív dűnek érzem egy egy olyant
amelyik energizál egy szent dű amelyik
amelyik abból fakad hogy látod a
potenciált és a potenciál közötti és a
realitás és a potenciál közötti
különbséget
ékes ami lelkesít is egyszerre mer mert
van destruktív fajta dű is amelyik
egyszerűen észe és akkor emiatt arra
gondoltál hogy ez egy egyszeri lehetőség
hogyha ezt nem ragadod meg én most nem
akarom a szádba adni a szavakat hogyha
utána elmondod hogy hogy jól
fogalmazom-e meg ez egy egyszeri
lehetőség és hogyha ezt most nem ragadod
meg ha nem mész előre akkor lehet hogy
majd a halálos ágyadon arra gondolsz
hogy mi lett volna ha akkor igen merek
mondani minden
minden racionális érv ellenére és és
igen mondtál emiatt igen meg hát én azt
gondolom hogy megengedhetem magamnak
mert olyan élth helyzetben is vagyok
hogy tudok foglalkozni a várossal akarok
vannak
ötleteim lehet vagy valószínű hogyha ez
a lehetőség négy év múlva merül fel
akkor már nem ilyen helyzetben lennék és
akkor már máshol kellene
kompromisszumokat kötnöm most én azt
gondolom hogy minden adott volt és
ráadásul megmérettettem is és nem férek
a megméretkezéstől és kimondottan
kíváncsi voltam hogy egyrészt meg
tudok-e felelni ezeknek a kihívásoknak
azért tényleg rengeteg emberrel kellett
megismerkednem megkapnom a közös hangot
és mindezt úgy hogy ne felelőtlen
ígéreteket tegyünk tehát hogy négy év
múlva is ugyanezeknek az embereknek
tudjak a szemében nézni és azt mondani
hogy igen mi erről beszéltünk és ha nem
is tudtuk megoldani ezeket a lépéseket
azért elindított tehát foglalkoztunk
ezzel az
üggyel úgyhogy minden összeállt a végére
és én egy egyébként egy ilyen típusú
ember vagyok az élet minden területén
tehát nem vagyok az a hogyha
magánéletről beszélünk ez a hősszerelmes
aki valakiben nagyon szeret de
fokozatosan megszeret valakit és itt
is nem voltam tüzesen lelkes de
fokozatosan és folyamatosan
belelkesültem és egyre inkább vonzott ez
a feladat és é azt éreztem hogy egyre
jobban akarom üüm és
és akkor ez most még tud fokozódni vagy
fokozódni tudott amiután lejárt ez a ez
a választási kampány is amiután eldőlt
hogy nyertünk igaz jött akkor az ijedség
akkor jött egy utazás egy kitisztulás és
akkor megint csak fokozódni tudott ez a
ez a tenni akarás és
és na tényleg várom ez ezzel
kapcsolatban nagyon kíváncsi vagyok a
véleményedre tehát jött a letisztulás
kíváncsi vagyok hogy mi az ami
letisztult benned azzal kapcsolatban
hogy hogyan lehetséges ez a ez az
elsőprő győzelem mi mi az üzenete ennek
számomra olyan volt mint amikor az ilyen
óceánokba dokumentumfilmekben látjuk az
óceánokban vannak ezek a halrajok és
mennek és mindenki egyszerre fordul
hirtelen a valahonnan tudja az a sok
százezer vagy akár millióh hogy ebbe a
pillanatban egyszerre kell megfordulni
hogy hogy mi az üzen ennek mit akart
ezzel udvarhely
üzenni neked vagy az rmds-nek mi volt a
a a mi az amit leszűrtél magadnak az
elmúlt 20 napban amíg szabadságon voltál
szerintem és azt még hozzátenném hogy te
is azt mondtad személyesen hogy egy
picit túl nagy győzelemnek tartod ezt
nem is picit túl nagy győzelem ü igen ez
egy összetett kérdés és akkor itt a
végével kezdeném a túl nagy győzelmet
amikor mondtam és ezt most is vállalom
akkor azt gondolom hogy ennek az a
hátulütője hogy nagyon sokan csodát
várnak csodát nem ígértünk nem vagyunk
képesek a jó isten képes egyedül csodát
tenni mi nem
de azt viszont vállaltuk hogy minden
téren lépésről lépésre egy fejlődés fog
elindulni a városban és egy összetett
kérdés hogy miért tudtunk ekkorát nyerni
egyrészt beszéltünk arról hogy a
választópolgárok egyáltalán nem hülyék
ők értékajánlatokat kapnak és ők úgy
látták hogy az az értékajánlat amivel mi
menni tudtunk az most a legjobb volt
vagy egyáltalán volt értékajánlatunk
mert hogy nagyon sok mindenkinek aki még
ezen a pályán mozgott és versenyzett nem
volt azt látták hogy hiteles emberek
állnak tehát hogy egy jó csapat van ez a
győzelem ez nem nekem köszönhető ez a
csapatnak köszönhető
olyan háttérembereknek is akik nem
mutatták meg az arcukat de a kampányban
végig velünk voltak tehát volt egy jó
kampánycsapatunk volt egy jó kampány
főnök nekünk van egy nagyon-nagyon jó
csapatunk egy
kompakt csapat azt gondolom tehát hogy
minden olyan kardinális vagy fontos
réteget meg tudtunk szólítani hiteles
emberekkel aki ami elképzelhető a
szépkorúakat a kulturális beállítottságú
embereket az oktatásban résztvevőket az
egészségügyben dolgozókat és ők mind
hiteles emberek voltak olyan emberek
akik hozzám hasonlóan
java része eddig soha nem vállalt
politikailag szerepet és én azt gondolom
hogy ezt is szimpatikusnak vette a
közönség és olyan emberek akik nem
szorulnak erre rá tehát nem megélhetési
politikusként vagy nem megélhetési
tanácsosként vagy adott esetben
polgármesterként érkeznek most
székelyudvarhely élére hanem tényleg
tenni akarnak és tényleg a közösséget
tartják a a szem előtt
én azt gondolom hogy a napvégén az az is
számított hogy hogy az rmds és furcsa
erről székelyudvarhelyen beszélni mert
nem egyértelmű a szervezetnek a
megítélése de most el tudtuk mondani a
városlakóknak azt hogy ahhoz hogy
gyorsabban és eredményesen fejlődni
tudjunk szükségünk van egy szervezetre a
hátunk mögé szükségünk van valakire aki
első úton beenged minket bukarestbe a
minisztériumba budapestre vagy éppen
brüsszelbe mert eddig is be tudtunk oda
jutni csak ez egy hosszadalmasabb út
volt és lehet amire célba értünk addig
elfogytak a pénzösszegek mert elvitték
azok akik a rövidített útszakaszon be
tudtak jutni tehát fontos ez a fajta
háttér is nekem személyesen is fontos
mert én érzek egy védelmi hátteret egy
védelmi mechanizmust is tehát hogyha
nekem kérdéseim vannak dilemmáim vannak
akár jogi akár bármilyen más akkor lesz
akihez forduljak és aki azt tudja
mondani hogy hát n nálunk ez előfordult
és én ezt ezt az utat választottam
hogyha nem egy családon belül lennék
akkor is valószínűleg eljutnák oda de
sokkal-sokkal lassabban és lehet hogy
arra már a döntést meg kellett volna
hozzam és hát nincs amiért tagadjuk itt
volt rengeteg protesztszavazat is aki
azt mondta hogy nem érdekel hogy ki lesz
nem érdekel hogy mi lesz de ez így nem
mehet tovább és ez és ezek mind
összegyűltek és ezek mind együtt adták
ezt a 80%-ot ami nagy győzelem és egyben
borzasztó nagy felelősség is és ennek a
tudatában kell a következő négy évben
intézkedéseket hozni illetve politizálni
is ha tetszik ez az epizód akkor kérlek
iratkozz fel a csatornánkra vagy írd meg
kommentbe hogy milyen más témáról
hallanál még szívesen szeretnék egy
provokatív kérdést is feltenni én
csikszeredaiként nem vagyok tisztában
azzal hogy az rmds reputációjait miért
negatív vagy miért volt ennyi ideig
negatív esetleg tudná mondani egy pár
szót erről hogy hogy mi volt itt ami ami
miatt ennyire ív megítélése volt az
elmúlt években és most hirtelen pozitív
irányba az most mondjuk arról
beszélgettünk hogy most megszavaztak egy
bizalmat ennek a szervezetnek és egy
hatalmas bizalmat de hogy mi történt mi
volt itt nem akarok
megbántani régi kollégákat régi tagokat
akik annó a legjobb meggyőződésem hogy a
legjobb tudásuk szerint és nem a saját
érdekeikre összpontosítva próbálták meg
adott esetben a szervezetet de akár
nyolc éven keresztül a várost is vezetni
de én azt gondolom hogy nagyon sokáig az
rmds-nek nem volt jó az értékajánlata és
ezért nem választották őket az emberek
ez ennyire egyszerű és a saját példámon
indulnék ki és ezt soha nem mondtam el
még nyilvánosan most úgy érzem
megengedhetem magamnak így van de én egy
nagy lokál patrióta vagyok tehát hogy én
hazajöttem mindig választani akkor is
amikor kolozsváron laktam akkor is
hogyha éppen a választás napján
budapesten voltam valamiért akkor
hazajöttem és a választottam és
helyihatósági választáson tehát
lokálisan én még soha nem szavaztam
rmds-re udvarhelyen és mindig mindig
hazajöttem voksolni parlamentin igen
helyhatóságin soha és nekem mindig az
volt a szempont hogy milyen az
értékajánlat milyen az miben más vagy
miben több az amit a az ellenfelekhez az
ellenlábasokhoz képest adni tud a
szervezet és eddig engem soha nem tudott
helyi szinten meggyőzni és milyen
érdekes most én voltam a jelöltje
[Zene]
de szóval csak ezzel akarnám azt is
illusztrálni hogy azért az rmds
mindamellett hogy fontos hogy egy
családnak vagyok részese és én magam is
szeretném építeni ebben a szervezetben
tehát fontos az hogy legyen nekem is egy
egyéniségem legyen egy langom ismerjenek
meg szervezeten belül is lássák hogy
vannak elképzeléseim van vízióm akarok
tenni valamit akarok tenni valamit a
városért de adott esetben hogyha már a
család tagja vagyok akkor a családért is
tehát hogy mindenféleképpen számíthatnak
rám
de de mindamellette ez a legjobb eszköz
tehát az rmdsz a legjobb eszköz most
hogy eljussunk bukarestbe budapestbe
vagy éppen brüsszelbe és jó vezetőként
jó vállalkozóként a legjobb eszközt kell
választani mindig tehát hogy ez egy
logikus döntés is volt egyben úgy
látszik a város tényleg egyszerre tudott
mozdulni mint egy harraj és és és és
tényleg erre a következtetésre jutott és
ez egy hatalmas felhatalmazás ami
egyszerre egy hatalmas teher is úgyhogy
örülök hogy ezt így podcast formájában
is megüzenhetted így a hallgatóknak hogy
ne csodát várjanak hanem hanem egy
fokozatos fejlődést és és egy fokozatos
folyamatos kommunikációt közben pontosan
tehát hogy együtt fogunk döntéseket
hozni tegnap voltunk ezt hogy képzeljem
úgy mint ilonmask feltesz majd egy-egy
kérdést a twitteren és akkor lehet
szavazni rá vagy a annál egy kicsit
átláthatóbban szeretném ezt az egészet
megvalósítani de nagyon sokat fogunk
konzultálni az emberekkel és nagyon apró
kérdésekben is és
ennek kétszeres értéke van tehát amikor
elmegyünk és felújítunk egy utcát tegnap
voltam a gábor áron utcában ahol egy
megnyert projektet kezdett el
kivitelezni a vállalkozás a lakosok
őszinte megdöbbenésére hogy itt óriási
felfordulás probléma parkolási gondok
kanalizálási gond ondok fognak
megtörténni és mondták hogy őket most
hívták ide először és
és nem a tervezési fázisban amikor a
legideálisabbnak tartanám hogy már akkor
együtt gondolkodjunk a lakosokkal és nem
kell ezt a két-három órát sajnálni mert
ez mindenkinek jó mert hogyha egy-két
kérdést előre tiztázunk és elindul ennek
megfelelően a nyertespályázat folyamán a
munka és felháborodnak a lakók mert ők
ebben nem gondoltak bele és akkor ők
hívnak össze már egy ilyen megmozdulást
és nyilván elmegy az ember akkor ez a
fegyver kétélű mert azt tudod mondani
hogy hát de kedves hölgyeim és mi erről
beszéltünk hát ezt önök döntötték el és
akkor nem könnyebb ez a politikusnak is
nem könnyebb azt mondani hogy ezt nem mi
döntöttük el ezt együtt megbeszéltük és
született egy döntés és és én ezt tudom
ígérni hogy mielőtt olyan új projektekbe
belefolynánk vagy belekezdenénk ami az
embereknek a lakókörnyezetét az
életterét nagyban befolyásolja már
előtte el fogunk kezdeni beszélgetni és
ez jó nagyon jó ő köáz legyenek egy-egy
döntésnek hanem aktív cselekvé ők
döntsenek az arról hogy mi az amit pont
konkrétan szeretnének és és a
felelősséget is akkor őkkel majd
vállalják de úgy általában hát te egy
vállalatvezető vagy nem esik jól
beszélgetni a kollégákkal évközben és
amikor nincsen probléma ezt ak te mint
polgármester és neked gyakorlatilag a
tehát van itt is egy ilyen viszony mint
adott esetben a vállalkozó vagy a
munkavállaló között most nem pont ez de
de de van egy ilyen jellegű viszony hogy
te függsz az emberektől
és az emberek is függnek tőled bizonyos
kérdésekben hát jól esik beszélgetni
bizonyos időközönként megkérdezni hogy
ők mit gondolnak erről és
és én azt gondolom hogy a
polgármesterhez kell vállalja egy leendő
polgármester is hogy sokat beszélgessen
a lakosokkal én most most is én mindig
hangsúlyozom hogy október végéig nem mi
vezetjük a várost mert polgármester úr
joga ezt ezt a négy évet végigvinni de
ahány helyre elhívtak elmentünk és
elmentem azért hogy szembesüljünk már
most problémákkal készüljünk fel deát
tudjuk hogy egyáltalán például a piacnál
egy rétegtalálkozót össze kell hívni a
piacos árusokkal hogy hogy ott
változtassunk bizonyos kérdéseken
legyenek ezek adójellegű kérdések
legyenek ezek különféle szegmentációk
hogy a termelők vagy a
kereskedők hnek hol legyen a az asztala
rengeteg kofával beszélgettünk rengeteg
árussal és hívnak és y jó eső érzés is
mert azt te látod hogy bíznak benned az
emberek tehát ezt a kellő bizalmat
megadják és nyilván ez egy ez egy
veszélyes dolog rengeteg új barátja lesz
az embernek
rengeteg tanácsadó jelentkezik aki már a
háttérben régóta nekem nekünk szurkol de
hát most most akar előjönni és most jött
el a pillanat hogy akkor ő konkrétan
hozza az
elképzeléseit kellő éretség mutattad a
facebook listádat is hogy a választási
éjszaka hány új barátod lett így
görgetted így több 10 vagy akár 100
kellőérettségkel ezeket a helyéen
kezelni mert hogy vannak egyébként
tényleg olyan emberek akiknek jó
meglátásaik vannak és vannak olyanok
akikről azért leri hogy érdekből
jelentkeztek vagy egyáltalán olyan
problémákat szeretnék veled meg
szeretnének veled megoldatni amik az
elmúlt 20 évben nem mentek át a szűrőn
és ez azért nem véletlen tehát hogyha
valamit nem lehetett megoldani 20 év
alatt úgy hogy azért nagyon vegyes volt
itt a politikai paletta és senki nem
tudott erre megoldást találni nem
valószínű hogy hogy az első mandátumban
én fogom megkapni itt a azt az
aranyközépúat amire adott esetben
szükség van úgyhogy ez is egy kihívás én
egy jó emberismerőnek tartom egyébként
magam és
igyekszem a helyén kezelni az embereket
de meg meg hát van egy szerencsém hiszen
ahogy beszélgettük erről egy kvázi
közintézménytől jövök jó viszonyok
alakultak ki más intézményvezetőkkel más
vezetőkkel
közintézményekből szóval én azt gondolom
hogy az elmúlt hét év tapasztalataaira
alapozva hiszen valljuk be hét évből egy
olyan öt évet egyáltalán nem volt bent a
leveg nem volt bent a levegőben hogy én
akár polgármester is lehetnék és már
akkor meg tudtam ismerni jó embereket és
azok a jó emberek nyilván most is jót
akarnak tehát hogy ő rájuk azért tudok
támaszkodni a tudásukra a meglátásukra a
tapasztalatukra és nyilván utána pedig
fel kell tudni mérni hogy hogy ki az aki
egyébként tényleg tenni akar ásból
jelentkezett most mert vannak olyanok is
igen meg amit említettél hogy személyes
kapcsolatban lenni az emberekkel
az emberek nincsenek hozzászokva ehhez a
személyes kapcsolathoz ez az egyik a
másik hogy ha valamiér valamiért
tapasztalatuk is van azzal hogy
meghallgatja őket a a politikai
vezetőség
akkor legtöbbször az a tapasztalatuk
hogy utána nem történik semmi tehát
leadnak egy dokumentumot elmondják a
véleményüket és azzal mint a füstbe vagy
mint a füst ahogy a levegőbe elszáll úgy
úgy gyakorlatilag ez ez ez elszáll én
érteni vélem hogy te ezt nem szeretnéd
és gyanítom hogy ez is a tervet hogy
ezeket nagyon komolyan vedd ezeket a a a
jelzéseket az emberek részéről ezeket
desztiláld valamilyen formában egy
esszenciává valami hog és ezeket és
visszajelzéseket adni az embereknek jó
persze minden nem lehetséges tehát ezért
kell prioritizálni ezért kell
desztilálni a dolgokat
nekem tetszik lássuk hogy ez meg fog-e
tudni valósulni ebbe a formában gyanítom
hogy az emberek most picit cinizmussal
picit
kérdéssel
néznek feléd vagy rád hogy hogy mi fog
történni ab és ezt nem lehet csak idővel
orvosolni tehát hogyha látják hogy hogy
komolyan vetted és látják azt hogy hogy
megbízhatnak akkor kinyílnak és és
sokszor ezt tapasztalom amúgy a a az én
körömben is én int informatikus most
körülbelül olyan 30-40 emberért felelek
ebben a pillanatban é sokszor az van
hogy amikor egy új emberrel kezdek el
beszélgetni látom a szemén ezt a
cinizmust látom ezt a bizalmatlanságot
hogy ha most én kérek is tőle valamit az
első reakciója az hogy bár amúgy
tiszteletteljesen beszélget de mégis
átérzem azt a a a a a tekintetén
keresztül hogy ő nem úgy gondolja hogy
hogy ennek semmi értelme ennek a
beszélgetésnek mert én úgyis el fogom
felejteni
úgyis az lesz amit én szeretnék én most
egy
manipulatív szándékkal mondtam azt amit
mondtam azért hogy azt az érzetet
keltsen benne minth hogyha érdekelne az
ő véleménye de úgyis az lesz amit én
akarok nem pedig ami ő amit ő és ezt
rendszeresen észrevettem hogy amikor
viszont komolyan veszem akkor az emberek
egyszer megdöbbennek elgondolkoznak és
utána vérszemet kapnak rájönnek arra
hogy te jó ég nekem is van
autoritásom komolyan veszik azt amit
mondok úgyhogy én is komolyan kell
vegyem magam hogy mit mondok ne csak
locsogjak össze-evissza úgyhogy gyanítom
hogy ez lesz hogyha ezt tényleg komolyan
veszed akkor egyre minőségib tanácsokat
fogsz kapni egyre jobban végiggondolják
az emberek hogy mit mikor mernek téged
zavarni mert rájönnek arra hogy te
komolyan fogod venni őket és hogy ők
fognak megszégyenülni hogyha most csak
össze-vissza locsognak és ennek az lesz
a következménye szerintem hogy hogy már
szinte ilyen akcióterveket kapsz hogy
polgármester úr ez a tervem így lehetne
megvalósítani hogyan tudnánk előre menni
és akkor csak egy igent vagy nemet kell
mondjál menjetek akkor előre és és a hát
háttérben ott leszek amennyire csak
lehet versus a a az
áldozatmentalitásból megfogalmazott
tervek hogy ez is jó lenne meg az is jó
lenne meg így kellett volna csinálni
annoó még meg meg úgy kellett volna
csinálni úgyhogy úgyhogy hajrá tehát én
embereknél nyilván ez nem skálázható
annyira mintogyha ez egy termék lenne
vagy egy szolgáltatás amit kifejlesztesz
vállalkozásnál vagy egyáltalán nem
skálázható olyan szempontból sem hogy te
a kollégáidat megválogatod azért
bizonyos szempontból ráadásul te egy
olyan szerencsés helyzetben vagy hogy te
értékek mentén válogatsz elsősorban
hogyha jól tudom hogyha jól ismertelek
meg nyilván ez nem adatik meg egy
polgármest a jellem fontosabb mint a
kompetencia nálunk ühüm
ellenben amit fontosnak látok és talán
ezt is érinthetnénk egy kicsit és már
érintettük is akkor amikor azt mondtuk
hogy minden egyes szervezet intézmény
előbb-utóbb hasonulni kezd a vezetőjére
hogy ezt átvegyék a kollégák is tehát én
egy kicsit azt látom hogy az egyik
legnagyobb gond itt a városban hogy
elfelejtettünk beszélgetni a
városlakókkal és most azt ezt hivatali
szinten vagy akár ha úgy tetszik
alárendelt intézmények szintjén is
mondom és akkor adott esetben meg kell
nézni hogy nem-e kell egy magatartási
kódexet vagy neme kell valamit kitalálni
amiben rávezetjük az elején az embereket
arra ami természetes hogy nyitottnak
kell lenni és el kell magyarázni
dolgokat a városlakóknak tehát akkor
amikor most egy városlakó háborog azon
hogy tegyük fel a személyzetnyilvántartó
irodánál nagyon sokat kell a személyiért
várni ez egyébként nem igaz pont tegnap
voltam személyt hosszabbítani és most
már egyik napról a másikra lehet kérni
programálást de ez csak egy példa volt
amúgy ez mindenkinek vagy a
polgármesterernek nem ezt mindenkinek
tehát hogy itt nem is hívtam fel
teljesen online én is ki akartam
próbálni meg akartam tapasztalni hogy
hogyan működik most ez a dolog vagy akár
amikor egy építkezési engedélyt kér vagy
nem é é hogy miért kell bizonyos
munkálatokra építkezési engedély ezt el
kell magyarázni az embereknek ha úgy
tetszik és erre nincsen idő mert nagyon
túlterheltek a kollégák akkor le kell
írni valahova közérthetően úgy hogy
konyhanyelven legyen ez megfogalmazva és
azt kell mondani az embernek hogy itt
írja hogy mi miért tart három napot
leírja azt hogy ő három napon át mind
dolgozik tehát hogy miért nem lehet ezt
helyben megoldani illetve nagyon
fontosnak látnám egyébként azt is
hú most nem akarok nagyon ugrálni vagy
cikázni a gondolatok között de nagyon
sok van ilyen szempontból hogy hogy
őszinték legyünk az emberekkel tehát
amikor elkezdünk felásni egy utcát akkor
tegyünk ki egy ktzer 2 mes táblát ahol
nem csak azt írjuk le ki ássa ki a
megrendelő milyen pénzből mennyi hanem
hogy mennyit fog tartani adott esetben
írjuk rá azt is hogy miért tart annyit
számoljunk rá egy hetet hogy ez reális
legyen tehát ha ha tudjuk hogy a
munkálat egy hónap lesz akkor írjuk azt
hogy ez öt hetet fog tartani azért hogy
őszinték legyünk az emberekkel bántóak
őszintén bántóan őszinték hogyha kell
tehát az emberek hozzászoktak most már
sajnos a rossz hérekhez is tehát mondjuk
el nekik azt hogy mi fog rájuk várni én
amikor én félek egyébként az orvosoktól
testvérem is orvos de én nem szeretem az
ilyen
beavatkozásokat és emlékszem amikor
fogorvosnál a fog orvoshoz mentem is én
sokkal jobban értékeltem ha azt mondják
hogy ez ez most fájni fog egy kicsit
mintha azt mondják hogy nem fog fájni és
puff vagy nagyon igen igen igen igen
igen igen igen szóval én én ennek vagyok
a híve legyünk őszinték legyünk bántóan
őszinték hogyha azt kívánja meg a
helyzet de beszélgessünk velünk és az
alárendelt intézmények és a
helyiendőrség is mondja el őszintén hogy
mi vár arra aki ezt meghozza de
beszélgessen az ember ne büntessen
beszélgessen ugyanígy minden más aki a
polgármesteri hivatal
alárendeltségébe
tartozik ezt a jó szokásomat nagyon
szeretném ha átvenni hogy sokat
beszéljen az emberekkel és mindig
őszintén tegye ezt meg és és viselje el
azt hogyha ennek az az ára hogy első
felindulásból kap egy nagyon rossz
választ ezt el kell fogadni ez amúgy egy
amúgy egy elv is ilyen szempontból hogy
a felnőttekkel így érdemes beszélgetni a
gyerekek azok akiket meg kell védjünk
bizonyos realitástól tehát a világ
kegyetlenségétől a komplexitásától meg
kell védjük a gyermekeimet é én én nem
úgy beszélek a gyermekeimmel hogy hogy
el hogy hogy rátegyem azt a terhet ami
egy felnőtthöz méltó lebutítom nyilván
mindig arra a szintre ahol ő van és egy
kicsivel talán meg
a fölötte levő szinten hogy úgy
növekedjen de nyilván az egy mesterséges
környezet ahol megvédem a legtöbb
dologtól én úgy érzem hogy nem kell a
felnőtteket megvédeni el kell mondani
személyesen nekik hogy mi a helyzet és a
kampányt is erre építetted és a
városlakok ezt is szavazták meg tehát
hogy én nem láttam akkora nagy egetverű
ígéreteket abban a kampányban hogy ami
irreális lenne én is azt gondolom hogy
nincs tehát hogy most nagyon sokszor
elhangzik ez hogy brutális ígéreteket
tettünk és ezzel megvezettük a
városlakókat ez meg
váható hát nagyon sokan önkormányzati
képviselők is így válasás után még egy
két héttel osztogatták a
programfüzetünket hogy ezt is
megígértétek azt is na majd lássuk mi
lesz a
vége én azt gondolom hogy nem ígértünk
lehetetlen tehát hogy ezt a programot mi
fenntartjuk hogyha valamit nem tudunk
megvalósítani azért ez egy 100 ügy volt
amit ott felsoroltunk akkor azt meg
fogjuk magyarázni úgy hogy a városlakó
is megértse hogy miért nem tudtuk
megvalósítani és ő majd dönt hogy ez egy
bocsánatos bűn és én elhiszem hogy
valóban ilyen akadályokba ütköztek de
megpróbálták vagy pedig nem ez nem egy
bocsánatos bűn mert hazudott abba a 100
pontba és a 75-et nem tudta megoldani és
ezt majd eldönti a városlakotát rájuk
kell az ő bölcsességükre kell bízni
magunkat és nem kell félnünk
[Zene]
tudnak ők mérlegelni üüm egy témakör van
amiről szeretnék egy kicsit beszélgetni
ugy a ha a jellemünket nézzük akkor azt
látjuk hogy van öt nagy dimenzió így
most egy ilyen
személyiségtesztet hogyha elvégeznénk
akkor van az a big five amit én nagyon
szeretek ott öt dimenzióra
osztja a személyiségét egy embernek és
az egyik dimenzió az a megértési szint
aki magas a megértési szintben mint
például én is azok általában nagyon
empatikusak kedvesek nagyon-nagyon hamar
ráéreznek a a másik személyre a
jellemére és ennek vannak hátulütői is
mint például a konfliktus külés én egy
konfliktus kerülő személy vagyok tudom
magamról engem hihetetlenül stresszel
egy konfliktus nem szeretem a
konfliktusokat rengeteg energiát elvesz
tőlem tehát én ezt tudom magamról és és
ezen nem tudok változtatni én ilyen
vagyok és amúgy senki sem tud tehát
amikor a 20-as évei után az a a a a a
jellemünk már kezd úgymond
megszilárdulni aki extrovertált az
extrovertált marad aki introvertált az
introvertált marad akin akinek magas a
megértési szinte annak magasa lesz a
megértési szintje és ez ezt jó ha tudjuk
magunkról én jó ha tudom magamról hogy
hogy hogy én egy empatikus személy
vagyok és minden egyes konfliktus engem
mindig le fog
fárasztani és a
konfliktuskerülésnek az egyik rágfenéje
az a kétszínűség hogy amiatt mert félünk
nemet mondani valakinek amiatt inkább
hajlamosak vagyunk féligent mondani és a
féligenből már egy idő után már
kétszínűévé válunk és én tudom hogy
ezzel kell küzdjek és az elmúlt éveknek
az egyik nagy fejlődési területe az
életemben pont ez volt hogy meg kellett
tanuljak úgy felvállalni konfliktusokat
habár nem szeretem habár rühellem hogy
hogy feszültség legyen nem érzem ha
bemegyek egy terembe érzem hogy
feszültség van-e vagy nincs és és
rühelem ha feszültség van én szeretem a
békét szeretem a kedves embereket
szeretek kacagni mosolyogni
szeretek
ünnepelni és tudom hogy te is hasonló
vagy érzem érzem rajtad hogy te is egy
egy konflikt amúgy a vita alatt is meg
is említetted mint amit tudod magadról
hog egy konfliktus kerülő személy vagy
és így ahogy beszélgettem sok sok
emberrel beszélgettem nagyon-nagyon
kíváncsi voltam mi fog történni ez alatt
a választás alatt nekem ez egy ilyen
ilyen ez egy kísérlet volt nagyon-nagyon
sokat gondolkoztam rajta beszélgettem
emberekkel és volt néhány kritika is
amit megfogalmaztak veled szembbe amit
te is megfogalmaztál magaddal szemben de
például ilyeneket mondtak hogy ez egy
seelyen fiú ez ez abban a pillanatban
mihelyt az első konfliktus jön összeesik
és gyakorlatilag most fogalmaztad meg
hogy az előnye az hogy az rmds van
mögötted egy egyre egyszerre hátrány is
olyan szempontból hogy ha van egy merev
szervezet amelyik
már több mint 20 éve vagy hány éves is
az rmds
hát 90-ben alakult 90-ben alakult akkor
34 éves
hogyha ha van egy ilyen merev szervezet
akkor akkor mennyire leszel képes egy
merev szervezettel szembe képviselni a
te akaratodat mennyire mennyire leszel
képes arra hogy hogy a kritikát elviseld
és lesz kritika mert mindenféle érdekek
vannak már most érzed és és hogyha a
napodat azt tölti ki hogy mindenféle
érdekek mentén mindenféle emberek jönnek
mindenféle tanáccsal támadással és néha
igazságtalan támadással ugyanakkor ahhoz
hogy hogy a terveit azt a víziót amit
amit kollektívan megálmodtatok azt végig
is tudjátok vinni kollektívan tehát hogy
ahhoz hogy tartani tudd ezt az irányt
oda rengeteg rengeteg konfrontációra
lesz majd szükség akár rmds-en belül is
te hogy érzed hogy ez ez ez ezzel hogyan
fogsz tudni
megbirkózni mindenhol rengeteg
konfrontáció lesz tehát hogy ezt ezt
nyilvánvalóan
látom és tapasztalni is fogom és erre
próbálok tudatosan is készülni és a
konfliktus kerüléssel kapcsolatban hát
szerintem az utam nekem pont olyan volt
mint a tiéd tehát alapvetően én egy-egy
konfliktuson hát volt hogy nem tudtam
aludni amikor először intézményvezető
lettem és
megdolgozott és akkor ahogy jöttek a
konfliktusok és az utóbbi évben azért ez
kicsúcsosodott rendre egyre jobban le
tudtam zárni és egyre inkább megtanultam
azáltal hogy megismertem magam hogy mi
az amire már alapból nemet mondok azért
hogy ne kerüljek féligenes helyzetekbe
rengeteg féligenes helyzet volt és
vártam hogy hogyan tudok majd ebből
nemet csinálni egy külső tényező egybe
valamit ki tudok-e találni mert nem
szívesen vállalom ezt az egészet és
akkor nem mertem nemet mondani szóval
minél több ilyen helyzetbe kerülsz
szembe annál inkább megedződsz hozzá
megismered saját magad nagyon pontosan
megfogod tudod tudni fogalmazni hogy mi
az amire hát csak féligent kell mondjál
de még azért valahogy vállalható szinten
meg tudod ezt valósítani és nem okoz
álmatraan éjszakát és mi az amire
egyértelműen nemet mondasz és ebben úgy
ér hogy tényleg nagyon sokat fejlődtem
nagyon sokat fejlődtem abban is hogy
amikor ilyen konfliktus van én nagyon
gyakran ilyen maró gunnyal vagy
iróniával szoktam lezárni és nagyon
belegázoltam az elején kollégáknak a
lelki életébe vagy úgy úgy egyáltalán
láttam hogy nagyon mény nyomot hagyott a
reakcióm bennük szóval ezeket most már
egészen jól tudom kezelni nem vonzom a
konfliktusokat tehát nem fogok újakat
behozni ez egészen bizonyos
de nem ijedek meg nagyon a
konfliktusoktól most már és ezt látom
szervezeten belül is hogyha esetleg
ilyen konfliktusokra kerül sor hogy én
nem vagyok egy régi motoros a
szervezeten belü nincsenek is
különösebben én azt én amikor azt
mondtam hogy magam szervezeten belül is
építeni akarom az egy belső motiváció
mert én ilyen vagyok mert én egész
egyszerűen szeretem megmutatni hogy
nekem van saját elképzelés van egy
vagyok egy egyéniség vannak gondolat a
im szeretném hogyha úgy éreznék hogy van
olyan terület amiben adott esetben én
lehetek a szervezetnek egy döntő arcca
vagy egy fontos
arca
de de ez saját magam miatt van és és
hogyha esetleg ez nem fog sikerülni
akkor akkor nem okoz problémát addig
amíg a közösségnek nem okoz problémát
és és amúgy mindennél azt látom hogy
nekem a legnagyobb aduász amiért
konfliktusokat is fel tudok merni
vállalni az pont ez az átok amiről néha
beszélünk ez a 80% hogy amíg én a
közösséggel vagyok és amíg mögöttem van
80%-nyi lakosság addig én bátran
vállalok konfliktusokat a közösség
érdekében vannak nekem olyan barátaim
akik elmerik mondani hogy né ez talán
túl sok né ez nem a mi érdekünkben
történik né te megváltoztál ez a
legfontosabb talán ettő félek a
legjobban egyébként a következő négy
évben hogy ne változzak meg és
és erre vannak barátaim akik frankon meg
fogják mondani hogy hát te amúgy nem
ilyen voltál vagy ilyen a családtagja a
családtagjaim már valamiért mondják hogy
egy kicsit megváltoztam a barátok ezt
nem észlelik még érdekes módon és
nyilván minden ilyen új jellegű projekt
főleg ez okoz valamilyen szintű
változást de ez nem lehet egy gyökeres
változás vagy nem lehet egy olyan
változás ami emberi minőségedet
befolyásolja én azt gondolom
de akár a szokásaidat is tehát hogy
nekem van egy pár olyan szokásom amit
szeretek és megtartanék például a
fallabdázás vagy például az hogy én
nyugodtan be tudjak üldni kávézni vagy
adott esetben meginni két sört akár egy
központi akár egy lakónegyedi lokálba
azért mert én ezt szoktam ezt szeretem
és nem nem akarom megváltoztatni tehát
valószínű most jön majd egy ilyen furább
helyzet is akik még nem is merm hogy
néha polgármester úr megiszik vagy néha
polgármester úr fröccsözik egyet hát én
ilyen vagyok és ezt nem akarom mert
nekem ez fontos így teljes a napom így
érzem teljes értékűnek ha úgy tetszik a
a hónapom hogy a barátaimmal is eltöltök
időt és én ezt nem egy hétvégi háznál
teszek vagy nem kiülünk egy kertbe
valahová hanem a városban az emberek
között én ilyen vagyok és amíg az
emberek között tudok maradni addig lesz
egy olyan erő ami
aminek hála fel fogok tudni vállalni
konfliktusokat és nem keresem de
felvállalom tehát beleállok bizonyos
kérdésekbe
egészen addig amíg amíg ez a most
tényleg nem elcsépelt közhelynek hangzik
hogy ez a közösség érdekét szolgálja de
valamilyen szinten most csak ezt kell
válaszolnom hogy amíg megvan ez a
támogatottságom és úgy érzem hogy ezt a
konfliktust székelyudvarhelyért vagy az
udvarhely székelyekért teszem addig
addig ebbe bátran beleállok ühüm ezt
erre pont rá is akartam kérdezni amit
mondtál hogy van egy védőhálód aki a
barátokból és a családtagokból áll akik
egyflytában visszajelzést adnak neked és
és segítenek abban hogy otthon érezd
magad hogy hogy megbízhassa az ő
visszajelzéseikbe mert mert sok sokféle
visszajelzéseket fogsz majd kapni a
következő időszakb
gyakorlatilag akkor ez az a podcast ez
egy ez egy szócső nekik is hogy mennyire
fontos gyakorlatilag praktikusan
mennyire fontos az ő szerepük ab
teljesen és ott is egyébként fontos hogy
jól lássad hogy mit akar adott esetben
egy barát vagy egy családtag is mert
hogy vannak olyan alá beállítottságak
akik nem akarták hogy én politikai
pályára álljak és akkor nyilván ezt úgy
kell mérlegelni az ő véleményüket van
akik nem akarták de elfogadták és
támogatnak nekik meg megint másképp de
így izgalmas és így érdekes ez a a dolog
én én ezt szeretem egyébként a az a
barátnak a definícióját az a legjobb
definíciója számomra amit eddig kaptam
az az hogy az a barátunk aki a legjobb
oldalunknak a legjobbat akarja és ez
azért egy nagyon érdekes mondat mert
vannak olyan emberek vagy legalábbis
főleg a a
ttinédzserkoromat jellemezték hogy
voltak olyan idézőjeles barátaim akik
nem a legjobb oldalamnak akarták a
legjobbat hanem voltak olyan oldalaim
amik nem feltétlenül volt tak jók de
mégis azokat jutalmazták azok most az
ivós cimboráimról beszélek meg a a a
partizós énemről
és és tényleg hogyha vannak ilyen
emberek körülötted akik a legjobb
oldaladnak a legjobbat akarják azok és
és megbízhatsz a véleményükben akkor
akkor azok hihetetlenül értékes kincs
lesz így a a a következő időszakb
én meg meg ott van például az is ami
amikor elkezd valaki fogyni hogy nek fog
egy diétának és emlékszem amikor én
hirtelen idézőjelben hirtelen egy fél év
alatt leadtam vagy ti plusz kilót jaj
nem ismerem ezt az érzést nem
ismer akkor jöttek ezek a a a
visszajelzések rokonok részéről akik
alig ismertek engem hogy jaj de beesett
az arcod milyen sáppat vagy ez már nem
áll jól neked ez már túl sok le kell
álljál azért azért kell a a férfinak a a
pluszsúly és nem volt az az érzésem hogy
a legjobb oldalamnak a legjobbat akarják
üüm úgyhogy
úgyhogy csak ismételni tudom hogy ezt
kívánom neked mert az a teher ami ami
ami vár rád ahhoz egyszerűen
elviselhetetlen hogyha nincs egy ilyen
érzelmi burok körülötted ami ami segít a
tisztán látásba
igen váltanék most egy másik témára is
ami számomra nagyon érdekes és talán
szervezetfejlesztési szempontból most ez
a legérdekesebb kérdés számomra nem
tudom hogy követted-e azt hogy mi
történt amikor elon musk átvette a
twittert persze persze persze az emberek
75%-át elbocsájtotta amúgy pont ma jött
ki a hír hogy megnyerte azt a pert
amivel az elbocsátott alkalmazottak
perelték elon muskot és mindenkik nyerte
meg mask nyerte meg mask nyerte meg és
mindenki azt nézte hogy most mi fog
történni a twitterrel tehát a 25%- az
embereknek hogyha ha tehát mi ha 75%-a
elmegy és 5%-al marad akkor össze fog
omlani ez a szervezet és én sejtettem
hogy miért csinálja ezt mask de most ezt
úgy fogalmaznám meg hogy ez a paretto
elvnek a a az élő bizonyítéka hogy
hogyan működik a parettoelv erről volt
egy előző epizódunkb szó ez a 8020-as
szabály ez ez azt jelenti hogy egy ugy
egy szervezeten belül is egy szűk
kisebbség az embereknek annyi terhet és
felelősséget visz a vállán mint az
összes többi sőt ennek matematikai
képletei is van gyök alatt ahány ember
dolgozik egy szervezetnél annyi terhet
visz magán mint az összes többi tehát
hogyha most én a városházát nézem akkor
akkor a
100 220-at 220-at káb igen a 220
embernek most mennyi a 220-nak a
gyöke 16 körül van tehát 16-17 ember
annyi terhet visz a vállán annyira
kompetens mint az összes többi ez ez ez
ez nem a városházára egy pecsét ez ez
gyakorlatilag ez egy természe törvény
minden így működik a bolygók méretétől a
folyóknak a vízhozamától kezdve a a a
focisták által rúgott gólok száma is
paret toev alapján oszlik el és ezt
látom amúgy nagyobb szervezetekben is a
ahol most dolgozom ott is ezt látom és a
saját csapatomon belül is ezt látom és
elon musknak is a twitterénél is ez ez
volt hogy gyakorlatilag elbocsátotta a
75%-át mert a maradék 25% annyira
kompetens volt és most is hogy képes
volt azt a szervezetet fenntartani sőt
megkönnyebbült ez a szervezet és sokkal
sokkal pörgősebben tudott
működni a kérdésem a következő te mire
számítasz hogy mit fogsz találni
októberben amikor a városházára mész és
és körbenézel és lesz melletted 220
ember akit akit közelről egy részét
ismered tudom de mind a 220 embert nem
hát meg kölcsönös előítéletekkel
szembesülünk adott esetben tehát hogy én
is így ahogy mondtad vagy érintettük
hogy megismertem jó néhány embert
bizonyos szempontból és bizonyos
szemszögből ők is gondolnak rólam
valamit gondolnak rólam valamit mint
intézményvezető mint rmdszes politikus
mint polgármester jelölt akárhogyan
szerinted mit gondolnak rólad
amúgy szerintem nagyon sokan azt hogy
hogy ahogy te is fogalmaztán nem fogom
megbírni ezt a feladatot és és össze
fogok roppanni egy-egy nehéz kérdésnél
sokan azért tudom hogy várnak és várták
azt hogy jöjjön egy másfajta hangulat a
hivatalba és kicsit próbáljuk felépíteni
azt ami egyébként megvolt annó tehát egy
ilyen kölcsönös bizalmon alapuló
újraszerveződés történjen meg nagyon
sokannak meg
mindegym nem érdekli őket tehát hogy ők
a polgármesterre egy
ilyen
vázó így van négy-nyolc évente változó
személyéként
tekintenek és akkor még ebben a
kategóriában is van kettő akinek mindegy
ki a polgármester nem nagyon
akar többet vagy újat tanulni vagy
mutatni és várja azt a nyugdíjas éveket
amihez adott esetben még 30 év
szükségeltetik tehát nem az van hogy
ezek 65-68 éves emberek és még egy kettő
van nagyon sokan pedig igyekeznek az
éppen aktuális polgármesterrel együtt
tudni dolgozni együttműködni de nem
ragaszkodnak kimondottan hozzá most én
nem tudom hogy valamelyik helyes vagy
sem az semmiféleképpen nem helyes hogy
hogy valaki nem akar fejlődni vagy nem
akar többet mutatni vagy nem akar
fejlődni adott esetben a technológiai
változásokkal vagy bármilyen ilyen tehát
hogy ezeket azért én is azt gondolom
hogy valamilyen
szinten most nem akarom azt mondani hogy
irtani kell de de én azt gondolom hogy
hogy itt folyamatosan versenyhelyzetben
kell legyenek a alkalmazottak és a
közhivatalnokok is nem olyan egyszerű
mint iron mask esetében 75%-át leépíteni
a a hivatalnak és nem is gondolom hogy
indokolt egyébként egy ilyen nagy számú
leépítés nyilván nagyon fontosnak látom
hogy jöjjenek új hiteles emberek úgy
ahogy mi magunk mint rmds újjá tudtunk
szerveződni és nem az van hogy mindenki
teljesen új azért vannak tapasztalt
önkormányzati képviselők is vagy vannak
olyanok is akik eddig erősítettek
bennünket aztán nem és most visszatértek
tehát hogy ezért mondom hogy nagyon sok
színű és kompakt csapata van jelen
pillanatban az rmdsz tanácsosi
gárdájának is és a hivatalnál is azt
látom vissza kell hozni embereket újakat
kell behozni akiknek eddig nem volt
közigazgatási tapasztalatuk de szeretnék
hogyha lenne és szeretnének valamit
letenni a városnak azoltárán és meg kell
meg kell tartani az értékeinket akik
pedig elfásultak az elmúlt időszakban
vagy csalódtak akár vezetéselméleti
kérdésekben vagy akár nem kaptak
kellőképpen visszajelzést és éppen ezért
nem tudtak fejlődni vagy nem éreztették
hogy hogy azért a fejlődésnek is eljött
most már az ideje azokat pedig gattyába
kell
rázni nem számítok hát most én ilyen
ember vagyok
őszintén próbálom megközelíteni hogyha
hivatali apparátust nézem nem számítok
semmi jóra tehát azt látom hogy egy
picit elfásultak az emberek akarnak
dolgozni nem kaptak kellőképpen
visszajelzést nem volt talán az elmúlt
időszakban annyi örömben részük mint
amennyi jár mindenkinek aki dolgozik
tehát mindenki aki dolgozik egy kicsit
meg kell ünnepelni őket és vannak
sikeres projektek most is a
városházán vannak jó osztályok vannak jó
emberek ahol nem megfelelőek az
eredmények ott is nem feltétlenül emberi
hiba okozza hanem vannak akik nagyon
túlterheltek tehát hogy közös sikereket
meg kell ünnepelni ezt nagyon sokszor
elfelejtjük bármilyen szervezetben én is
elfelejtem az inkubát az ünneplésben
igen tehát hogy nekem is a kollégák akik
nagyon igényelnék hogy ünnepeljünk meg
egy-egy sikeres pályázatot egy-egy
sikeres pályázatnak a lezárását egy
sikeres programot mindig jelzik hogy hát
a főnök ezt kise beszél nem hogy nem
ünnepeltük meg ki se beszéltük alaposan
sajnos tényleg tényleg vannak ezek a
hibák
és
én mindenkivel beszélgetni fogok
beszélgetni fogunk közösen nyilván az
osztályvezetőkkel de mindenki mással aki
ezt igényli beszélgetni fogunk négy szem
közt
is folyamatosan szerzem általam
megbízhatott megbízható személyekről az
információkat hogy hogy hol milyen probl
ma lesz van van miért nem haladnak úgy a
dolgok vagy miért nehezebb egy-egy
osztálynak a működése erre külön
abszolút kendőzetlenül rá fogunk térni
így az elején és mondom ez a
hivatal nagyon más lesz a többiekhez
képest olyan szempontból hogy nyitottá
akarom tenni tehát azt akarom hogy adott
esetben az emberek is lássák hogy itt
munka zajlik tehát hogy ne az legyen
hogy bezárunk egy hivatali ajtót hogy ne
jöjjön be aki és nem azért mert éppen
szendvicset majd szólgatunk hanem azért
mert annyi munkánk van hogy egyszerűen
ha bejön az ember elveszti elveszíti a
kedves hivatali alkalmazot a fókus és
még fél órát nem tud kell köret ahhoz
hogy hogy t ő most úgy érzi hogy kell én
pedig úgy érzem hogy egy kicsit a
magyarországi kormányablakoktól is
tanulhatnánk be kell vinni ezeket az
embereket is a a nép közé tehát hogy nem
feltétlenül kell a polgármesteri hivatal
ban dolgozzon minden egyes osztály üüm
egyrészt nem kell hogyha úgy tetszik egy
nagyon banális példát
mondjak nem jó ez a központi forgalom
vagy parkolás szempontjából sem tehát
ott áll most a polgármesteri hivatal
előtt x számú autó ami önkormányzati
alkalmazottak és elvesz elveszítünk
értékes parkolóhelyeket amiket egyébként
kiudnánk adni vagy amit élvezhetnének a
városlakók azok akiknek kisebb vagy
nagyobb ügyes bajos dolgaik vannak egy
hétköznap a városban de viszont meg
lehet nézni vagy meg kell próbálni
szétszórni ezeket az embereket jobb
munkakörülményeket tudunk nekik
biztosítani y virágos irodába tudjuk
betenni őket emberek között
vannak normálisan az emberek is be
tudnak sétálni kapnak egy kis ülőhelyet
el tudnak egy pohárvizet egy kútból
venni adott esetben hogyha várakozniuk
kell és én nem riadnék meg attól hogy a
város különböző részeire tegyünk be
bizonyos osztályokat egy inkubátorházba
egy belső felső betlen negyedbe ahol
vannak ilyen területek amiket ilyen
szempontból hasznosítani tudunk hát
bátran menjünk el a a városakok közé
ilyen szempontból is és akkor akkor
nézzük meg hát hogyha jobban lehet
gyakorolni ezt a nyitást ha többet
beszélgetünk az emberekkel meggyőződésem
hogy így lehet gyakorolni deehát maga a
polgármesteri hivatal maga az épület is
ott előbb-utóbb azért egy alapos
felújításra van szükség hát azért látjuk
hogy most nincsen morális alapunk a
központban egyébként rengeteg
nem megfelelő állagú épülett
tulajdonosával beszélgetni arról hogy jó
lenne hogyha egy egységes szép
városközpontja legyen udvarhelynek és
ehhez nagyon fontos az hogy mindenki a
saját központi házát ingatlanját újítsa
fel és egy olyan színvonalon és egy
olyan
egy olyan stílusban ami ami
székelyudvarhelyhez méltó de nincsen
morális alapunk mert hogy a hivatal is
esik szét jelen pillanatban tehát hogy
rendet kell tegyünk ott is ami
előbb-utóbb így is úgy is költözéssel
fog járni és meg kell teremtsük az ehhez
szükséges forrásokat is és hát akkor már
miért ne ötvözzük a kettőt menjünk elébe
a dolgoknak amíg megkapjuk a pénzt addig
egy kicsit legyenek bizonyos osztályok
az emberek között vannak akik ott vannak
egy lakosságnyilvántartó iroda most is
el van
különítve de de máshol is egyébként
meggyőződésem hogy ez szóba jöhet
úgyhogy
nagy
türelemmel tényleg a lehető leg
előítéletes
előítéletmentesebben fogom megszólítani
a kollégákat és nagyon nyitottra leszek
a közös munkára a közös gondolkodásra
elsősorban a közös gondolkodásra én
nagyon szeretem hogyha olyan emberekkel
tudok együtt dolgozni a akik nem csak
dolgoznak hanem gondolkodnak is és
jönnek javaslatokkal hogy ez mindenki
érdeke város érdeke a munkavállaló
érdeke hiszen ő valószínű olyan
javaslatot fogalmaz meg ami könnyebbé
teszi a hétköznapjait és hogyha ez
esetleg megmutatkozik operativitásbeli
különbséggel vagy akár egy élménnyel tud
távozni a városlakó az akkor
mindenképpen
beültetésre kerül tehát hogy ezt akkor
akkor meg fogjuk valósítani
mindannyiunkér érdekében meg kell nézni
a vezető beosztású személyeket hogy ott
milyen helyzetek vannak azért vannak még
fontos pozíciók egy városházán egy
alpolgármester egy főjegyző egy
városmenedzser tehát hogy ott ott mi a
helyzet ott mennyire nyitottak a közös
munkára ezek az emberek vannak olyanok
amik már be vannak töltve vannak olyanok
akiket olyan helyzetben vagyunk hogy mi
tudunk odavinni milyen beállítottságú
legyen az új alpolgármester az új
városmenedzser
van már ötleted hogy ki lesz a az
alpolgármester
ötletem nincs de viszont vannak
elképzeléseim és azt gondolom nagyon sok
munkát várok tőle is és egy olyan embert
szeretnék aki aki szintén egy olyan
élethelyzetbe tudja hozni magát hogy az
előtérbe tudja helyezni a várost tehát
hogy ma a család daltisztázza hogy akkor
egy picit kevesebbet fog a következő
négy évben velük lenni mert nagyon sok
munka lesz és nyilván azt szeretném
hogyha kiegészítenénk egymást tehát
hogyha ő olyan területen rendelkezne
tudással amin én nem nem vagyok
mindentudó nyilván egy csomó területhez
nem értek nagyon fontos hogy hogy
megbízzunk egymásban tehát hogy azokon a
területeken ő gyakorlatilag előbb-utóbb
tejhatalmat fog kapni én nem szeretném
ellenőrizni őt de fontos ahhoz hogy hogy
ezt megkaphassa hogy jól megismerjük
egymást hiszen a nap végén és ez a
hivatali
kollégákhoz is egy üzenet a nap végén én
fogom vállalni a felelősséget
mindenkinek a hibájáért és nem akarom
hogy nagyon sokat hibázzunk tehát hogy
ők is most kapnak egy védőhálót nem
fogjuk azt mondani hogy hát ezt irénke
néni annyira elcseszte hogy hogy hogy
nincs amit csináljunk és akkor kiállunk
a sajtó meg a hivatal közösségi oldalára
és elmondjuk hogy irénke a hibás nem
hogyha itt hibázunk akkor én leszek a
hibás de nem akarom hogy nagyon sokat
hibázzunk üüm ez a ami amit beszéltünk a
paret toevről akkor összesítve
egyetértesz ezzel hogy egy szervezeten
belül így oszlik el a a munkavégzés a
munkavégzés mennyisége hogy egy szűk
kisebbsége sokkal több munkát végez két
tehát annyit végez mint az összes többi
tehát ez létezhető hogy 17 ember annyi
munkát végezzen a városházán belül mint
az összes többi vezetős elmélet
területén ezzel egyetértek ugyanakkor
nagyon sok végrehajtó kell a városházára
és ezt nem bér írná meg é tehát bizonyos
szempontból egyet tudok érteni nyilván
ez nem mondható el hogyha itt most 220
ember helyett 16 renne akkor akkor
ugyanígy t a felét végzi el a tehát az
az állítás hogy 17 ember elvégzi a felét
a munkának és a másik felét az összes
többi ez létezhet hogy ez ez ez igaz
legyen létezhet egy vállalkozásnál én
nem feltétlenül tudok egyetérteni egy
önkormányzatnál erre amúgy nagyon
kíváncsi leszek hogy mi az amit fogsz
majd találni ben nem is kérdés hogy
létezhet-e ez így
mindenesetre te megemlítettél két tábort
szerintem azért van négy tábor még
kettővel kiegészíteném amit te meg
megemlítettél vannak azok akik nek
irreleváns hogy te ott vagy vannak azok
akik nek nem irreleváns de személytelen
ühüm vannak viszont azok akik
kifejezetten várnak személyesen téged és
gyanítom hogy lesz egy olyan tábor is
akik kifejezetten nem várnak személyesen
téged gondoltam menjünk végig mind a
négy táboron és mit üzennél nekik
menjünk először a azok akik kedvelik
szíuszt üüm mit üzennél nekik hát hogy
igyekszem majd úgy dolgozni hogy négy év
múlva is kedveljenek és velük nyilván ők
valamiért kedvelnek és én merem remélni
hogy inkább azért mert tudják hogy
nyitott vagyok a
változásokra tudják hogy szeretem az
innovációt az újszerűséget és és ő
neekik a azt üzenem és arra biztatom
hogy beszéljenek nagyon sokat velem mert
nagyon nyitott leszek meghallgatni az ő
javaslataikat és igyekszem azt amit az
inkubátorházban egy mikrokörnyezetben
meg tudtunk valósítani áthozni a
polgármesteri hivatalba is és nagyon
szükségem van rájuk mert hogy egész
egyszerűen ez a mentalitásváltás
bekövetkezzen ezt nem fogom tudni
egyedül megoldani és ők valószínű olyan
szemléletű emberek mint én és hogyha azt
látják minden irodában hogy hogy van egy
ember aki ezt képviseli akkor az adott
irodában is
könnyebben fognak megváltozni vagy
könnyebben fognak nyitani a lakosság
fele nagyon elcsépelt megint ez a
lakosságbarátönkormányzat de én nagyon
azt akarom hogy mi azok legyünk és tudom
hogy nagyon sok olyan akadály van ami
miatt egyes osztályuk ezt nem tudják
megtenni mertogy hálátrrá a feladatuk
gyakorlatilag de őket is arra fogom
biztatni hogy ő sőszinteséggel adott
esetben nyers őszinteséggel is tehát el
kell mondani a város rakónak azt is ami
fáj
ezt ezt meg lehet küszöbölni és akkor
csak mondjuk úgy el az őszinte helyzetet
hogy hogy lehet hogy csak egy kávét kell
adni még a még a velem szemben ülő
félnek szóval arra kérem őket hogy hogy
legyenek őszinték mindig és hogyha
bármilyen olyan ötrletük van amik úgy
érzik hogy segíthetik a közös munkát
akkor jelezzék van-e valami amit külön
azoknak üzensz akik nem kedvelik
sinzíuszt és nem várják hogy te odamenj
mert ez úgy úgy tűn nekem mint hogyha
valójában mindenkinek üzented volna amit
most mondtál
szeretném megérteni hogy ez miért
történhet meg
nyilván nem fogják a szemedbe mondani
nyilván hogy nem fogják a szemembe
mondani de nyilván valamiért nem
kedvelnek és ez egyébként nem jó tehát
nem jó egy olyan főnökkel együtt
dolgozni ráadásul ez egyezzünk meg hogy
négy év valószínű így is úgy is lesz ha
nagyon nagyot nem
hibázok én azt gondolom hogy ha valaki
úgy érzi hogy nem fogjuk tudni megkapni
a közös hangot mert mert nem nem
szívesen dolgozna velem együtt nem tart
szimpatikusnak nem értékeli kimondottan
azt a szakmái múltat amit amit magam
mögött hagyok hogy hogy ne szenvedjen
akkor
üjünkre beszélgessük megnéz meg van-e
esetleg olyan alintézmény ahol jól
érezné magát vagy nézze meg hogy nem-e
járna jobban hogyha egy olyan főnöke
lenne akit szeretne szóval mi van ha
csendesen szabotál arra rájövök h és
akkor mi lesz hogyha csendesen szabotál
tehát hogy itt megint egy olyan dolog
van
amiről nagyon keveset beszélünk hogy
nagyon nehéz közhivatalnokokat
elbocsátani vagy arra rávenni hogy ők el
elhagyják a pontosan polgármester nehéz
de nem lehetetlen különféle példák
vannak erre vannak nagyon extrém példák
a legtöbben felszokták hozni a
nagyváradi polgármester bolozsán ha nem
tévedek aki nagyváradot
egy nagyon szép fejlődő pályára
állította és utána azt mondta és
teljesen önként hogy elég volt ő elmenne
a megyei tanács élére óriás többséggel
választották meg és az első
indtészkedése az volt hogy hát majdnem
ilyen parató elv mentén nem pont ilyen
arányban de a a kollégáknak a felét
elbocsátotta osztályokat szüntetett meg
teljesen új embereket vitt oda és ők
ővele szoktak érvelni azok akik akik
nagyon támogatják azt hogy ilyen óriás
forradalom legyen hivatalokban de ezt
nem szabad elfelejteni hogy ő is
rengeteg perrel szembesült és nagyon sok
per most jár le tehát ennek az árát ők
is most fogják megfizetni vagy most
fizetgetik meg nem ilyen egyértelmű a
dolog de viszont az sem igaz a másik
oldalon hogy lehetetlen lenne elküldeni
okosan jól felépítve kell aki nem akar
dolgozni aki nem tud dolgozni aki nem
nyitott a változásra az egész egyszerűen
nem lesz amit keressen napvégén a
polgármesteri hivatalban tehát én nem
tudok olyan én a kollégáknak is mindig
jelzem és van amikor el tudom fogadni az
érveiket hogy rossz napjuk van olyan
élethelyzetben vannak de én nem tudok
olyan emberrel dolgozni akinek a
szemében nem látok egyfajta lelkesedést
és én észreveszem hogy h valaki lelkes
vagy nem tehát
tényleg nagyon fontosnak látom azt hogy
hogy egy irányba húzzunk
és azt is megértem hogyha esetleg néha
az evező elkallódik de húzzon valamerre
húzzon
mármint lehetőleg abba az irányba
lehetőleg abba az irányba azért igen
szóval
aki egyáltalán nem akar velem dolgozni
azt azt tényleg azt mondom hogy a saját
maga érdekében nézze meg hogy nem-e
talál máshol nagyon nagy munkaerőigény
van a város vállalkozásainál ezek az
emberek azért zömmel én azt gondolom
hogy értékesek tudnak lenni tehát nincs
nincs az a probléma ha valaki nem
szereti a főnököt tehát hogy ezzel ez ez
teljesen természetes emberi vonás emberi
tulajdonság de hogy ne menjen ez rá az
egészségére hogy ne menjen ez rá arra a
16 hat órára amit nem a munkahelyén tölt
és ne mutatkozzon meg alvatalanságban
vagy családbi konfliktusba is én azt
gondolom hogy ha valaki egyáltalán nem
szeret vagy úgy érzi hogy van egy olyan
konfliktusunk ami
áthidalhatatlan akkor egy kicsit nézzen
szét azért a munkaerőpiacon tehát hogyha
most én összegezni szeretném azt amit az
elmúlt 20 percben mondtál lásom hy jól
megértettem-e szeretnél egy gyökeres
változást hoz ide udvarhelyre ezért
fogtál neki ennek a a a ennek a
felkérésnek és ezért léptél bele ebbe a
a cipőben mert hát gyökerest azt nem úgy
értem hogy mindent meg fogunk fordítani
ma szeretnél egy egy radikális
megújulást olyan területeken ahol látod
a potenciálját ahol nem történt meg
eddig ahol dühös voltál ahol hogy miért
nem történik meg pedig megtörténhetne ez
egy rengeteg konfliktussal járó
rengeteg munkával járó feladat lesz és
el hívod a városháza alkalmazottait hogy
vegyenek részt ebbe ha részt vesznek
akkor akkor nagyon jól ki fogtok jönni
egymással ugyanis neked az a terved hogy
együtt dolgozz velük hogy a lehető
legtöbb dolgot delegálj hogy ne
mikromenedzserkedy hogy felelősséget
igazi felelősséget adj a kezükbe és egy
kaland legyen a munka együtt viszont
hogyha nem akarnak ebben részt venni
akkor minél hamarabb tudatosítsák ezt
magukba mert mert ezt így is úgy is
észre fogod venni ezt jól össze
összegeztem nagyjából igen annyival
azért
kiegészíteném hogy ez a gyökeres és
radikális változás ami nagyon meredeken
hangzik adott esetben az
azért nem azt jelenti hogy valami nagyon
komplex vagy valami nagyon egyedit
terveznék azt szeretném most
konyhanyelvre
lefordítani lefordítsam hogy mindig
meleg legyen a leves mert ez a leves
kihűlt és nagyon régóta kihűlt és nagyon
rég óta úgy adunk levest az embereknek
hogy vagy nem azt a levest kapják amit
kértek vagy pedig egy hideg levest
kaptak tehát természetes dolgokat
szeretnék bevezetni
őszinteséget nyitást várok
munkabíróképességet
várok a magam részéről pedig igyekszem
melléteni azt ami vezetői kompetencia
hogy mindig legyen munka hogy mindig
legyenek projektek hogy mindig legyenek
kihívások hogy megünnepeljük hogyha van
egy-egy sikerünk és és hogy jó legyen a
hangulat mert hogy azért az is
számít nagyon fontosnak látom azt és
erről megint csak majd személyesen fogok
tudok tudni meggyőződni hogy itt jó
kollégák legyenek hogy ismerjék meg
egymást az emberek hogy ne halljam azt
négy év múlva hogy valaki rendszeresen
munkaidőben jár foglászhoz kozmetikába
turkálóba nézelődni hanem én nem mondom
hogy nem kell kiszapkadni az irodai
környezetből legyen egy jó kávézó ahol
beszélget egymással két olyan munkatárs
aki nem egy irodában van de mégis csak
egy hivatalért és egy ügyért küzd tehát
hogy igen nyugodtan lehet kávézni
nyugodtan lehet
beszélgetni ilyen jellegű
változások lesznek de én azt gondolom
hogy ezek természetesek kell legyenek
hát köszönöm szépen még rengeteg
kérdésem lenne sőt van egy pár kérdés
amit a halgatók tettek fel úgyhogy ilyen
villámkérdésszerűen ezeket felteszem
aztán meglátod hogy mennyire szeretnél
rájuk válaszolnim és hogy mennyire bőven
az első kérdésem az az ami engem is
foglalkoztat mi lesz a hbc-vel hát ott
egy versenyvizsga lesz egy új
intézményvezető fog odaérrkezni az
inkubátorházról azt tudni kell hogy a
megyei tanács területén fekszik a megyei
tanács az épületnek a tulajdonosa is és
az igazgatótanács pedig úgy néz ki hogy
oroszhegy
polgármestere van benne a megyei
tanácstól három tag székdvarhely
önkormányzatától ismét három tag és az
új fel állásban én felfüggesztem az
inkubátorházas pozíciómat négy évre ha a
törvény engedi akkor nagyon szeretnék az
igazgatótanácsnak a részese lenni és
úgymond egy figyelőszem lenni az
inkubátorházon nyilván nagyon értékesnek
tartom azt a munkát amit ott az elmúlt
hét évben letettünk a csapattal és nem
szeretném hogyha ennek a színvonala esne
és ez egy áldás mert egy nagyon jó
intézményt kap meg valaki egy átok mert
óriásiak az elvárások és egy dupla átok
mert ráá ul én mint régi igazgató is
őrködni fogok az inkubátorház fölött
úgyhogy egy vagány kompetens vezetőt
szeretnénk aki közel áll a
vállalkozókhoz ez valamilyen szinten egy
bizalmi kapcsolat és úgy látom a a a
hogy a vállalkozók elmennek egy
rendezvényre vagy támogatják az
inkubátorházat az azért van mert van egy
nagyfokú bizalmi kapcsolat is köztünk és
tudják tudták hogy az elmúlt hét évben
ami ót lezajlott az az igényes az
őszinte az előremutató és tudták hogy
olyan társaság jár oda akiktől
kölcsönösen tudnak tanulni ezt szeretném
hogyha fenntartanák és nyilván a
bentrakokkal hangsúlyosan kell
foglalkozni nagyon büszke vagyok azokra
az eredményekre amiket az a közel 200
cég elért aki tőlünk kiment már
üüm az egyik hallgató a magánéletedre
kérdezett rá azt kérdezte hogy
felolvasom érnek szíusz kelne mint
magánember is ha jól tudom elvált fiatal
talán single is ilyen téren mi történtek
az életében biztos hogy
izgalmas a magán mindenkinek a
magánélete azért meggyőződésem hogy
izgalmas
igen nem sok helyen beszéltünk arról
hogy valóban elvált vagyok
egy pár szót mondanál erről hogy ez ez
mikor én nem tudtam amúgy pontosabban
most tudtam meg a kampány alatt de
nyilván azért ásták elő hogy hogy áljak
ezzel egy egy van kedved egy pár szót
mondani erről persze gyakorlatilag
kolozsváron ismerkedtem meg a a volt
feleségemmel ő marosvásárhelyen a a
orvosképzésen vett részt egy nefrológus
veseorvos aztán együtt költöztünk haza
székelyudvarhelyre ez már egy kihívás
volt egyébként a kapcsolatban ő
nagyvárosi életet képzel el magának én
pedig azért mindenképpen ragaszkodtam
hogy jöjjünk haza itt voltak a barátaim
itt vannak a gyökereim itt vannak a
család á vagy itt volt a család és én
tényleg itt szerettem volna
tevékenykedni úgyhogy ott már volt egy
nagyfajta ingás a kapcsolatunkban és
aztán végül ez ebből nem sikerült alpra
állnunk úgyhogy azt láttuk jónak hogyha
lezárjuk ezt a kapcsolatot barátságosan
nagyon jól tudtuk lezárni és egyébként
ez jellemző a
magánéletben rám hogy ott is azért
igyekszem hogyha valamiért arra kerül
sor és elég sokszor arra kerül az elmúlt
időben hogy le kellett zárni egy
kapcsolatot ezt mindenképpen jól
megtenni azt az minőségi időt amit
együtt töltöttünk azt értékelni nem
szidni a másikat hiszen akkor valamilyen
szinten saját magunkat is szidjuk hiszen
mi éltünk együtt az illető emberre az
utolsó kapcsolatom az egyébként pont év
végén év elején ért véget ez egy négy
éves kapcsolat volt és itt is egészen
békésen váltunk el és mindig úgy hozta
az élet és ez valószínű nem len hogy
olyan hölgyekkel kerültem kapcsolatba
akik értelmesek akik nyilván vonzóak
hiszen azért szerettem beléjük akik
megálltak a saját lábukon úgyhogy soha
nem volt ez egy probléma ők karakánon
mindig ki tudtak lépni egy kapcsolatból
mindig boldogultak mindig értékes és
vagány munkát végeztek el úgyhogy
úgyhogy na így alakult az életem hm
ezen része én tuti most még kérdeznék
párat időnk nem lesz rá és lehet hogy
majd a a kamerákon kívül majd még
kérdezek mit ígér a fiataloknak az
udvarhelyi ifjúság élete meghalt az
elmúlt években üüm igen ezt külső és
belső tényezők is befolyásolják
meggyőződésem hát külső tényezőről mikor
beszélünk a pandémia megkerülhetettlen a
pandémia olyan emberi és
fiatalság szempontjából szintén nagyon
releváns
igényeket ölt meg ha úgy tetszik vagy
alakította át az emberiséget hogy ennek
áldozata lett
nagyon sok szempontból az ifjúsági élet
hát gondoljunk arra hogy van sajnos egy
olyan korosztály amelyik a középiskolai
négy évét pandémiában töltötte le ő
nagyon sok mindenről kimaradt és amikor
ő hogyha azt választotta hogy tovább
tanul vagy munkába áll akkor teljesen
más igényei illetve értékei alakultak ki
a pandémia négy éve alatt
mindamellett udvarhelyen
azért megszűntek szórakozóhelyek nagyon
sok szórakozóhely hát most tudunk nem
egy rádióműsorban vagyunk tudunk konkrét
nevekről beszélni azért régebb amikor én
hazaköltöztem udvarhelyre akkor volt egy
felsőgé egy alsóg egy spion egy mokka
egy kalapos egy ezeknek azért jó része
megszűnt és akkor amikor ott arról
beszélgettünk hogy akár egy ilyen
buliutcát is létre lehetne hozni a
városban
most azt látjuk hogy ezek a helyek
szépen lassan egytől egyig bezártak
illetve korlátozótak hát most láttam
hogy az egyik hely is most hétfő kedden
már nem nyit ki csak szerdától
vasárnapig a megmaradtak között is és
nyilván fogyasztók is kevesebben lettek
ugyan akkor nyilván valamilyen szinten
akadályba is ütköztek és nem tudtak
olyan minőségi programokat adni ami
megfelelt volna a központi lakosok
elvárásainak adott esetben az
önkormányzat vagy a helyi őrségnek az
elvárásainak is és a legjobb példa erre
az a tavalyi ted meghívottunk lucian
mruc aki eljött hozzánk kükülőszállodáb
volt elszállásolva és este 10 órakor
kitett egy képet a szálloda ablakából
hogy ő mennyire jól érzi magát
székelyudvarhelyen hiszen beesteledett
és teljesen kihalt a város senki nincs
milyen szép békés hely ez az udvarhely
és és akkor megint van az embernek egy
kettős érzése mert hogy végül is mi egy
megyei jogú városban lakunk egy ifjúsági
városban egy iskolavárosban jó-e az hogy
este 10: órakor mindenki eltűnik az
utcáról szerintem nem üüm de azt is
elfogadom aki szerint ez egy szép dolog
én valamiért úgy érzem hogyha valaki
csendre vágyik vagy arra vágyik
hogy ne legyen élet egyáltalán körülötte
és ő sötétedés után
a tücsökcsiripelést hallgassa akkor
talán keltvárosba vagy vidékre kellene
költöznie mert a városban én azt szoktam
meg hogy mindig van egyfajta mozgolódás
egyfajta nyüzsgés a nagy városokra
szokták mondani hát most kolozsvár is
átvette de hoshimin cityből érkeztem
hogy hoshimin city never sleps vagy
éppen kolozsvár is hogy soha nem alszik
a város és valahol én a város
definíciójába ezt be is hoznám hogy
amúgy kell élet legyen a városban mit
üzenek a fiataloknak azt hogy létre
fogunk hozni egy ifjúsági stratégiát és
együtt letesszük ennek az alapszabályait
hogy miben tud segíteni most a város hol
adhat esetleg könnyítéseket
beazonosítunk olyan területeket ahol az
ifjak jól érezhetik magukat nyilván
korlátozni kell mert hogy ez egy
olyan közeg akik most feszegetik a
határaikat minden téren de de én egy
aktív ifjúsági életet szeretnék ahhoz
hogy székelyudvarhely valóban
iskolaváros tudjon maradni vagy
iskolaváros legyen nagyon sokak szerint
elvesztette ezt a státuszt nagyon fontos
hogy az ifjaknak tudjunk ilyen
szempontból is lehetőségeket adni hogy
hogy élvezhessék az életet úgyhogy ilyen
tekintetben is ígérek változásokat
ígérünk változásokat foglalkozni fogunk
a fiatalok kérdésével önkormányzati
képviselők jöttek be akik csak fiatalok
ügyeivel fognak foglalkozni ennek
megfelelően majdnem mindent átalakítunk
városnapoktól ifjúsági fesztiválon át
megnéz nézzük azt hogy hol lehet esetleg
olyan területet beazonosítani ahol ők ők
jól érezhettik magukat este is tehát
hogy lehet egy-két buliról is szó
nyilván ezt piaci alapon vállalkozókkal
közösen kell kitalálni és kellenek olyan
kockázatbevállaló vagy kockázatra éhes
vállalkozók akik ezeket az igényeket ki
tudják vagy kierik elégíteni de
meggyőződésem hogy vannak úgyhogy
elkezdjük felépíteni székelyv helyt
ifjúsági szempontból is újjáépíteni ha
úgy tetszik izgatottan várom és
ahogy magán beszélgetésünkben is ígértem
hogy ha elindulsz akkor én segíteni
szeretnék neked ezt így négy szem közt
is még egyszer megismétlem hogy hogy
ameddig ezen az úton ezekkel az elvekkel
fogsz tudni járni előre addig én is
szívesen részt veszek ebbe és szívesen
segíteni fogok ebben nagyon sok
mindenről beszélgettünk nekem egy nagyon
tartalmas beszélgetés volt é köszönöm
neked én is így értékelem és köszönöm a
lehetőséget egy jó élmény volt köszönöm
szabor köszönöm szépen ha tetszett ez a
műsor akkor iratkozz fel kérlek a
csatornánkra ezzel tudsz támogatni
minket köszönjük a vckker
kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre